LIBRARY OF CONGRESS. .
.
SPEAKER:  GOOD AFTERNOON.  WHAT
A PANEL WE HAVE HERE TODAY.
WE'RE IN FOR A TREAT.  I'M KAREN
LLOYD, DIRECTOR OF THE PROJECT
AND IT'S MY PLEASURE TO WELCOME
YOU TO THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
BUILDING IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
THE INFORMATION CENTER WHICH IS
LOCATED ACROSS THE STREET IN THE
MADISON BUILDING IS A MYA
ANDREW QUOTE WHICH PERHAPS YOU
HEARD BEFORE.  THERE IS NO
GREATER AGONY THAN TELLING AN
UNBEARING STORY INSIDE YOU.
MONDAY IS MEMORIAL DAY.  TAKE A
MINUTE TO REMEMBER THE LIVES WHO
GAVE THEIR LIVES TO OUR
COUNTRY.  THE ULTIMATE
SACRIFICE.  WE SHOULD BE MINDFUL
THAT MANY WHO DID NOT RETURN
HOME FROM WAR, WE ARE GATHERED
HERE TODAY.  POST TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER, PTSD, THE
INVISIBLE WOUND THAT AFFECTS
HUNDREDS OF VETERANS.  OVER 30%
OF VIETNAM VETERANS AND OVER 10%
OF IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN
VETERANS EXPERIENCE PTSD.  IT'S
NOT JUST THE COMBAT VETS AT
RISK.  SEXUAL ASSAULT AND TRAUMA
CAN PRODUCE THIS DEBILITATING
DISORDER.
PTSD CAN AFFECT THE VETERANS'
ABILITY TO WORK, INTERACT WITH
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.  AND JUST TO
LIVE.  WHILE IT'S A MAJOR
FACTOR IN VETERANS BECOMING
INVOLVED AND ALSO A MAJOR FACTOR
WITH VETERANS BECOMING INVOLVED
WITH OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHILE WE ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE VETERAN'S PROJECT, AND
CANNOT CURE PTSD, UNBURDENING
THE WEIGHT OF THEIR STORY
PROVIDES SOME RELIEF.  AT THE
VETERANS HISTORY PROJECT, WE
MAKE RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO
RESEARCHERS SO THEY CAN BE
BETTER UNDERSTOOD.  WE HOLD
EVENTS LIKE THIS TO LET VETERANS
KNOW THEY ARE NOT ALONE.  TO
RAISE THE AWARENESS LIKE THE
VETERANS TREATMENT CORE THAT
CREATES POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
VETERANS WITH PTSD.  TODAY YOU
WILL HEAR PLENTY OF IDEAS ABOUT
PTSD AND VETERANS TREATMENT
COURT.  THOSE IDEAS WILL BE
USELESS IF THEY STAY IN THIS
ROOM.  I HOPE YOU WILL LEARN
SOMETHING FROM THIS PANEL AND
KEEP IT WITH YOU AND USE IT TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN SOMEONE'S
LIFE.  EVEN IF IN A SMALL WAY.
JUNE IS NATIONAL PTSD AWARENESS
MONTH.  THE PERFECT TIME TO GET
INVOLVED.  WHETHER IT'S
VOLUNTEERING WITH THE VETERANS
SERVICE ORGANIZATION OR
INTERVIEWING THE VETERAN IN YOUR
LIFE FOR VHP.
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TODAY TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
PTSD AND HOW WE CAN SUPPORT OUR
VETERANS.  IT IS NOW MY PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE OUR KEYNOTE
SPEAKER, CNN'S VERY OWN CHIEF
WASHINGTON CORRESPONDENT, MR.
JAKE TAPPER.  [APPLAUSE].
INVITING ME TO SPEAK BEFORE SUCH
AN IMPORTANT GROUP OF PEOPLE,
HAVING SUCH A CRUCIAL
CONVERSATION.  I DID NOT SERVE.
BUT I COVER PEOPLE WHO DID, AND
WHO DO.  IT IS THE HONOR AND
RESPONSIBILITY OF WHAT I DO TO
TELL THESE STORIES.  AND IT IS
THE HONOR OF A LIFETIME TO DO
SO.  I THOUGHT THAT THE BEST
THING I CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THIS
EVENT WOULD BE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
A YOUNG MAN NAMED ED FAWKNER
JUNIOR AND MAYBE THROUGH HIS
STORY, PEOPLE COULD COME TO
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE STRUGGLES
AND SOME OF THE REASONS WHY
PTSD EXACTS THE TOLE THAT IT
DOES.
AND WHY PEOPLE HAVE SUCH A
DIFFICULT TIME FIGURING OUT HOW
TO FIX IT.  ED FOSTER JUNIOR WAS
FROM NORTH CAROLINA AND SERVED
WITH 361 CAMPS AND WAS ONE OF
THE MANY
HEROS DURING THE OCTOBER THIRD
2009 ATTACK ON COMBAT OUTPOST.
I WROTE A BOOK
ABOUT THE OUT POST.  AND THE
BOOK FOCUSES QUITE A BIT ON THE
HEROS WHO DO NOT MAKE IT HOME.
ED WAS A HERO WHO MADE IT HOME
AND NOT ABLE TO LEAVE THE BATTLE
BEHIND HIM.  AND I THOUGHT
SHARING HIS STORY MIGHT HELP
ALUMINATE THE CONVERSATION IN
SOME SMALL DEGREE.  AFTER THE
BATTLE WHERE ED WAS WOUNDED, HE
HAD A PURPLE HEART FROM SERVING
IN IRAQ.  AND DURING THE INTENSE
BATTLE OF COMBAT, HE WAS
WOUNDED AGAIN IN THE SAME SPOT
AND WAS PUMPED BECAUSE HE WAS
GOING TO HAVE TWO PURPLE HEARTS.
AND ONLY ONE SCAR.  WHICH HE
THOUGHT WAS NOT FAIR.  AFTER THE
BATTLE HE WAS SENT TO
RECUPERATE AT FORT CARSON IN
COLORADO WHERE HIS PHYSICAL
WOUNDS WERE TREATED.  AND HE WAS
IN PRIVATE SECOND CLASS AND HE
WAS ENCOURAGED TO REJOIN HIS
TEAM IN AFGHANISTAN.  THE
OFFICER ASKED HIM, DON'T YOU
WANT TO BE A REAL MAN AND RETURN
TO YOUR AFGHANISTAN UNIT?  HE
SAID
SOMETHING THAT HE DIDN'T THINK
HE WAS CAPABLE OF GOING BACK TO
WAR.  TOO MANY VOICES IN HIS
HEAD.  INTENSE NIGHTMARES.  AND
AN ARMY PHYSICIAN TOLD HIM THAT
HE HAD POST TRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER AND HE WAS ALREADY TO
BE FAIR TO THE ARMY.  AND HAD
COME INTO THE ARMY ALREADY.
SOMETHING THAT -- SOME SOMETHING
OF AN UNSTABLE PLACE
EMOTIONALLY.  AND THE
BATTLE HAD TIPPED HIM AT SORTS.
HE LOST TWO OF HIS BEST
FRIENDS.
MICHAEL SCUUZA AND GRIFFON.
DURING AN ATTEMPT TO SAVE FIVE
MEN WHO WERE TRAPPED IN A HUM-V,
HIM, GRIFFON AND ANOTHER GUY
NAMED JOSHUA HEART TRIED TO
RESCUE THEM.  AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THE THREE MEN IN THE RESCUE
TRUCK AND THE FIVE MEN THAT
WERE TRAPPED, ONLY THREE OF THEM
SURVIVED.  AND FAWKNER WAS ONE
OF THEM.  AND HE HAS, AS A LOT
OF PEOPLE HAVE, SURVIVOR'S
GUILT.
FAWKNER'S COMMANDER AT FORT
CARSON ALREADY SUSPECTED THAT HE
WAS SELF-MEDICATING WITH
ILLEGAL DRUGS AND HE THOUGHT IT
WAS CONTRIBUTING TO WHAT HE WAS
GOING THROUGH.  HE DECIDED IT
WOULD BE BETTER TO DISCHARGE
FAWKNER BEFORE HE GOT IN SO MUCH
TROUBLE THAT HE WAS
DISHONORABLEY DISCHARGED.  IT
UPSET HIS FATHER, FAWKNER
SENIOR.  THE SON NEEDED PHYSICAL
THERAPIST AND NOT HUMILIATION.
BUT THEY KICKED HIM OUT IN A WAY
THAT THEY THOUGHT HE WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THE VA AND THE
BENEFITS.  APRIL 1ST, 2010, ED
FAWKNER JUNIOR AND ED FAWKNER
SENIOR BOARDED A PLANE BACK TO
SOUTH CAROLINA.  AS SOON AS HE
GOT BACK TO NORTH CAROLINA, HE
RETREATED INTO HIS OWN HEAD.  HE
DID KEEP IN TOUCH WITH SOME OF
HIS FRIENDS ON FACEBOOK AND HE
DESCRIBED HIMSELF AS HAUNTED.
HE DREAMT ABOUT IRAQIS GOING TO
THEIR DOOR AND BRINGING DEAD
BABIES TO HIM.  HE SAID TO HIS
FATHER THAT HE COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING TO SAVE GRIFFON'S LIFE
BUT HE WAS NOT ABLE TO.  WHEN
THE MOON WAS OUT, HE WAS SCARED
AWAY BY NIGHTMARES.  MICHAEL
SCOOZA HIS FRIEND WAS ONCE ABLE
TO COMFORT FAWKNER.  AND HE WAS
NOW GONE.  AND WASN'T ABLE TO
SAY THAT ANYMORE.  IN APRIL
2010, STARTED IN A CLEANING JOB.
AND WOULD GET UP AT 6:00 A.M.
EVERY DAY AND THE BOSS SHOWED
HIM HOW TO USE THE VAN.
AND HE STEPPED INTO A BUCKET OF
HOT WATER AND SAID IT HURT THE
BLISTER WOUNDS.  HE TRIED TO
MAKE A LIFE FOR HIMSELF.  HE
WOULD STAY UP LATE AT NIGHT
WATCHING THE VIDEOS THAT WERE
POSTED ON YOUTUBE.  HE TOLD HIS
FRIENDS FROM 361 THAT HE HEARD
GUN FIRE AND SAW TALIBAN EVERY
DAY.  HIS FATHER TOOK HIM TO A
GREENS BOROUGH GRASS HOPPERS
GAME ON THE 4TH OF JULY.  WHEN
THE FIRE WORKS STARTED, FAWKNER
HIT THE GROUND, AS IF HE WAS
UNDER ATTACK.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT,
FAWKNER'S MOM COULD NOT FIND
HIM.  HE DIDN'T ANSWER HIS
CELLPHONE.  SHE DROVE AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND COULD NOT FIND
HIM ANYWHERE.  WHEN SHE
RETURNED TO THE DRIVEWAY, SHE
SAW A SHADOW IN THE BUSHES AND
SAW HER SON CROUCHED DOWN AS IF
HE HAD A RIFLE AND LOOKING
THROUGH THE SCOPE AS IF THERE
WAS AN ENEMY.
AND THERE WAS A RADIO AND HE WAS
TALKING TO IT LIKE HE WAS IN
COMBAT.  AND SHE GUIDED HIM HIS
BED.  AT THE END OF JULY 2010,
FAWKNER RAN NAKED IN THE STREET
AND YELLED THE END OF THE WORLD
HAS BEEN COMING AND STOPPED
PEOPLE IN THE STREET ASKING THEM
IF JESUS CHRIST WAS THEIR LORD
AND SAVIOR.  AND RECENTLY HAD
TRAP INJURIES AND SUFFERING FROM
PTSD.  I KNEW IT, SAID THE
POLICE OFFICER.  WHEN SHE
DETAINED HIM HE WAS TALKING ON
THE RADIO TO FELLOW SOLDIERS
THAT WERE NOT THERE.  THEY WERE
BOTH IMAGINARY.  THE POLICE DID
NOT WANT TO ARREST FAWKNER.
SARAH AGREED TO VISIT HIM.  AT
THE CENTER IN NORTH CAROLINA.
FIRST SHE WALKED RIGHT PAST HIS
ROOM.  MATTRESS WAS THROWN TO
THE FLOOR AND OCCUPANT WAS
COVERED VIA SHEET.  THE ROOM
BELONGED TO SOMEBODY ELSE.  NOT
HER BROTHER.  WHOEVER THAT IS,
BEFORE REALIZING IT WAS ED.  SHE
WALKED IN AND TRIED TO HAVE
CONVERSATION.  SOMETHING HAD
TAKEN HIM OVER.  SCARED HER.  I
CAN'T SIT IN THIS NUT HOUSE.
THE REALIZATION KNOCKED THE WIND
OUT OF HER.  MY BROTHER IS VERY
ILL RIGHT NOW.  HE SAID THIS IS
THE END FOR ME.  YOU HAVE NO
IDEA.  I AM SO STRESSED OUT.  I
DON'T KNOW WHY I DID WHAT I DID.
I DON'T KNOW WHY IT HAPPENED.
SHE TRIED TO TELL HIM TO GIVE
HIS LIFE OVER TO GOD AND ONLY
GOD CAN SAVE HIM.  NOT DRUGS.
THE TO HER, HER BROTHER SEEMED
BEYOND SAVING.
THERE IS ALL THIS NOISE IN MY
MIND HE TOLD HER.  IT WON'T
STOP.  WON'T QUIET DOWN.
FAWKNER WAS TRANSFERRED TO A
VETERAN'S HOSPITAL FOR A COUPLE
OF DAYS.  ASSIGNED A SOCIAL
WORKER AND THEN WAS DISCHARGED.
PARENTS WERE NOT IMPRESSED ABOUT
THE CARE THEIR SON HAD
RECEIVED.
SEEMED CASUAL AND OBLIVIOUS.  HE
REALLY NEEDED SOME HELP.
FATHER WOULD SAY IF YOU ARE OUT
IN A STORM, YOU SEEK SHELTER AND
HAD THE STORM GOING ON IN HIS
BRAIN.
BUT HIS GOVERNMENT, HIS COUNTRY
PROVIDED HIS SON WITH NO SUCH
SHELTER.  FAWKNER SOON MET A
WOMAN NAMED CHARLENE IN AUGUST
AND SHE SAID SHE SUFFERED FROM
DEPRESSION.  FOR THE FIRST TIME,
FAWKNER DID NOT FEEL ALONE.  HE
HAD CHARLENE.  SHE HAD A YOUNG
DAUGHTER.  HE HELPED HER WITH
HER HOMEWORK.  A NORMAL LIFE.
ALMOST.  HE MOVED INTO HER
APARTMENT WITHIN TWO WEEKS OF
MEETING
HER.  SHE WAS PROVIDED
BENEFITS.  AND ALL OF THIS
SEEMED ALARMING.  I DON'T HAVE
TO LIVE IN THE BIGGEST HOUSE HE
SAYS.  SO WHAT IF SHE IS ON
WELFARE OR HOUSING?  THESE
PEOPLE ARE CLOSE TO GOD.  GOT ON
THE PHONE ONCE WITH ED'S
CENTER.
SHE SEEMED SPACED OUT.  I CAN
TELL YOU'RE ON DRUGS SARAH
REPLIED.  LOCK THEM UP.  MY
BROTHER WAS ONCE ADDICTED TO
PAIN PILLS.  KEEP THEM OUT OF
HIS REACH.  SHE PROMISED SHE
WOULD.  SHE HAD A LITTLE GIRL AS
WELL.  ON THE NIGHT OF 15TH OF
SEPTEMBER 2010, FOUND DRIFTED
OFF ASLEEP BY THE STEERING
WHEEL.  WHEN ASKED WHAT WAS
WRONG, DIDN'T ANSWER.  THE NEXT
MORNING CHARLENE WOKE UP AND GOT
HER DAUGHTER READY TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND TOOK HER TO THE BUS
STOP.  SHE WAS SURPRISED TO SEE
ED WAS NOT MOVING AN INCH.  SHE
CALLED 911, THEY ARRIVED AND
TOOK OVER THE CPR.  THE FIRST
RESPONDERS NOTED THAT THERE WAS
SEVERAL BUCKETS OF MERKY WATER
IN THE HALLWAY.  THE MATTRESS ON
WHICH ED FAWKNER WAS LYING HAD
CIGARETTE BURNS AND PACKED WITH
PILES OF CLOTHING AND TRASH.
THE BATHROOMS WAS COATED WITH
FILTH.  THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
TECHNICIANS RAN IN AND CONFIRMED
THAT ED FAWKNER JUNIOR WAS
DEAD.
THEY WHEELED HIM OUT AND PLACED
HIM TO THE BACK OF THE EMERGENCY
ROOM.  THE CAUSE OF DEATH WAS
ACCUSE METHADONE TOXICITY.  A
FEW DAYS LATER, ADMINISTRATION
CALLED AND SAID, WOULD YOU
PLEASE LET YOUR SON KNOW HE IS
LATE FOR HIS APPOINTMENT.
AS WORDS READ, FORMER SERGEANT
JONATHAN HILL CALLED TY CARTER,
ANOTHER FELLOW SOLDIER TO HOUSE
HOW THE ARMY AND THE VA HAD
TURNED THEIR BACKS ON THEIR
FRIEND.  TY CARTER SAID I THINK
ED WAS THE 9TH VICTIM OF COP
KEEPING.  AND I DON'T THINK HE
WILL BE THE LAST.  THERE NEEDS
TO BE A PLACE IN SOCIETY FOR THE
ED FAWKNER JUNIORS OF THE
WORLD.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER.  I'M A
REPORTER.  I'M NOT A POLICY
MAKER.  WHETHER IT'S IN THE ARMY
OR THE VA OR IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES, THEY ARE NOT
SOMEBODY ELSE'S PROBLEM.  THEY
ARE NOT SOMEBODY IN THE STREET
JUST BLOCKING YOU FROM GETTING
TO WORK WHEN YOU WANT TO GET TO
WORK.  THEY ARE OUR PROBLEM.
THAT WE ARE NOT DOING ENOUGH TO
SAVE MEN LIKE ED FAWKNER JUNIOR
AND IT'S A NATIONAL DISGRACE
.
I'M GOING TO
INTRODUCE THE COUNCIL.
CURRENTLY SERVES AS PRESIDENT
FOR THE AMERICAN BAR
ASSOCIATION.  MELISSA FITZGERALD
IS BEST KNOWN FOR THE TV SERIES
WEST WING.  SHE LEFT HOLLYWOOD
TO LEAVE THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF DRUG COURT
PROFESSIONALS WHERE SHE WILL NOW
BE EXPANDING HER ROLE TO HEAD
UP A NEW INITIATIVE ADVANCING
JUSTICE.  I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO LISTEN TO
MY STORY ABOUT ED FAWKNER
JUNIOR AND I HOPE THIS STORY
TODAY PREVENTS FUTURE TRAGEDIES
FROM HAPPENING.  IT HAS BEEN MY
HONOR.  [APPLAUSE].  HONOR.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU JAKE FOR ALL
THAT YOU DO ON BEHALF
OF VETERANS.  AND I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK GREG CRAWFORD HERE ON
THE PANEL FROM THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF CORRECTIONS IN
JOINING US FOR THIS EVENT.  I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT AND THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
CORRECTIONS SUPPORT THE VETERANS
WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.  IT HAS
BEEN THE GREATEST HONOR OF MY
LIFE TO BE PART OF JUSTICE FOR
VETS.  AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS
HAVING A PROFOUND IMPACT AND
REAL IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.  I
AM EXCITED TO EXPAND MY ROLE AND
LAUNCH THE NEW INITIATIVE OF
ADVANCING JUSTICE.  I THINK WE
ALL KNOW THAT OUR VETERANS ARE
AMONG OUR NATION'S GREATEST AND
MOST VALUABLE CIVIC ASSETS.
THEY ARE THE BACKBONE OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY INSTILLED WITH
THE VALUES THAT MOST OF US
ASPIRE TO.  HONOR, DUTY,
LEADERSHIP, RESPECT.  WE KNOW
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
NATION'S VETERANS RETURN HOME AS
LEADERS, PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND VALUED LEADING
EXEMPLARY LIVES.  WE KNOW THAT
EVERYONE'S EXPERIENCE IS NOT THE
SAME.  WE CAN'T IGNORE THE FACT
THAT ONE IN FIVE VETERANS
RETURNING SUFFERS FROM PTSD AND
ONE IN SIX SUFFERS FROM A
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER.  WE
CANNOT IGNORE THE DEBILITATING
AFFECT OF TRAUMATIC BRAIN
INJURIES ON THE LIVES OF
MILITARY FAMILIES.  WE CANNOT
IGNORE THAT THESE ISSUES OFTEN
LEAD TO
HOMELESSNESS, UNEMPLOYMENT,
ARREST OR WORTH.
IF WE DO NOT INTERCEPT, THESE
VULNERABLE VETERANS AT THE KEY
MOMENT OF CRISIS, WE MAY NOT
HAVE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY.
INSTEAD OF SENDING OUR VETERANS
TO JAIL, VETERANS TREATMENT
COURTS ENSURE THAT THE VETERANS
WHO STRUGGLE WITH THE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDER.  AND/OR MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION TRAUMA, AND
WHAT THEY NEED TO GET THEIR
LIVES BACK ON TRACK.  VETERANS
TREATMENT COURTS GIVE OUR
VETERANS THOSE WHO DEFENDED OUR
FREEDOMS, THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FIGHT FOR THEIR OWN FREEDOM.
FREEDOM FROM ADDICTION AND
MENTAL ANGUISH AND UNEMPLOYMENT
AND HOMELESSNESS AND FREEDOM
FROM ISOLATION.  VETERANS
TREATMENT COURTS RECOGNIZE THAT
RESTORING OUR VETERANS TO
HEALTHY CITIZENS NOT ONLY HONOR
THEIR SACRIFICE.  IT MAKES OUR
COMMUNITIES STRONGER.  VETERANS
TREATMENT COURTS WORK.  THEY
HELP REDUCE CRIME AND THEY WORK
REDUCING TAXPAYER MONEY AND WORK
BY RETURNING HEALTHY VETERANS
TO OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
ARE GREATLY NEEDED AND WHERE
THEY BELONG.  AT JUSTICE FOR
VETS, IT IS OUR MISSION TO PUT A
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT WITHIN
REACH OF EVERY VETERAN IN NEED.
JUSTICE FOR VETS IS THE ONLY
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION COMMITTED
AND DEDICATED TO THE EXPANSION
OF VETERANS TREATMENT COURT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SAY THAT TODAY
THERE ARE 15,000 VETERANS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE INCARSERATED
IN THE 330 LIFE SAVING TREATMENT
CENTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND
WITH THAT, I WILL TURN IT OVER
TO YOU, BUTCH.
SPEAKER:  LET ME JUST BRIEFLY
ADD MY THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU TODAY
AND OFFER MY THANKS FOR ALL OF
YOU JOINING THIS CONVERSATION.
THE CONVERSATION THAT OUR NATION
MUST HAVE ABOUT PROVIDING A
HOLISTIC SOLUTION TO THE
CHALLENGES FACING SOME OF OUR
VETERANS.
WHEN A VETERAN AND HIS OR HER
CONDUCTS COMES INTO CONTACT WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OUR FEDERAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, OUR NATION, WE
HAVE A CHOICE.  A CHOICE BETWEEN
PLACING THEM IN A CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT MAY NOT HAVE
THE CAPACITY OR THE CAPABILITY
TO CONSIDER THEIR UNIQUE
EXPERIENCES AND CHALLENGES.  AND
A SYSTEM WHERE WE ARE LIKELY TO
SEE THEM AGAIN.  OR WE CAN MAKE
THE CHOICE THAT BECAUSE OF
THEIR SERVICE, WE ARE PLACING
THEM IN A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE UNIQUE
BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCES ARE
UNDERSTOOD.  AND THE SYSTEM
MELTS TREATMENT WITH INTENSE
SUPERVISION ALL AIMED AT
IMPROVING OUTCOMES.  IN OTHER
WORDS, PLACING THEM IN A
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT.
VETERANS TREATMENT COURTS, IF
YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
MODEL, ARE A FORM OF
PROBLEM-SOLVING COURTS.  DRUG
COURTS, WHICH NUMBER IN EXCESS
OF 3500 AND REALLY HAVE BEEN
PART OF OUR JURISPRUDENCE SINCE
1989.  PROBLEM SOLVING COURTS
LIKE DUI COURTS, WOMEN DRUG
COURTS, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, ALL
BUT TO NAME A FEW CREATED TO
ADDRESS THE SPECIFIC NEEDS AND
CREATE THE UNIQUE EXPERIENCES OF
THEIR POPULATION.  BUT IT
WASN'T UNTIL 2008 WHEN A
COURAGEOUS JUDGE AND HIS STAFF
IN BUFFALO, NEW YORK, RECOGNIZED
MORE COULD BE DONE TO IMPROVE
THE OUTCOMES OF VETERANS IN
THEIR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND A MOVEMENT BEGAN.  THEY
CHOSE, AGAIN, A MATTER OF
CHOICE.  THEY CHOSE TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.  AND
STARTED THE CONVERSATION.  THE
CONVERSATION TODAY WHICH ALL OF
US ARE PRIVILEGED TO CONTINUE.
I HAVE BEEN PART OF THESE COURTS
SINCE I RETIRED FROM THE ARMY
THREE AND A HALF YEARS AGO.  AND
THE ARMY TAUGHT ME TO BE A
BOTTOM LINE UP FRONT PERSON.
AND I HAVE HOWEVER, SPARED YOU
THE USE OF POWER POINT TODAY.
BUT MY BOTTOM LINE UP FRONT IS
THIS.  I BELIEVE THAT VETERANS
TREATMENT COURTS ARE THE
GOVERNMENT, JUDICIARY AND THE
COMMUNITY AT THEIR VERY, VERY
FINEST MOMENT.  IN TRYING TIMES,
IF YOU WANT TO BELIEVE IN
SOMETHING, I URGE YOU TO CHOOSE
TO BELIEVE IN THE VALUE OF
VETERANS TREATMENT COURTS.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
DISTINGUISHING FEATURES OF THESE
COURTS THAT I WILL HIGHLIGHT
FOR YOU.  SPECIAL INGREDIENTS,
IF YOU WILL.  THE USE OF
VOLUNTEER VETERAN MENTORS WHO
CHOOSE TO BE A PART OF THESE
COURTS.  TRUST ME.  NO ONE
RESPONDS TO A
VETERAN LIKE A VETERAN.  AND NO
ONE CARES FOR A VETERAN LIKE
ANOTHER VETERAN.  AND THEY
BECOME THEIR BATTLE BUDDIES.
JUSTICE OUT REACH OFFICERS,
GREAT NEW STORIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
THESE BJO'S AS THEY ARE CALLED,
SIT IN COURT AND ALMOST
INSTANTLY CONNECT THE JUSTICE
INVOLVED VETERANS TO BENEFIT
FROM THE SERVICES THAT THEY MAY
NOT OTHERWISE PURSUE.  BUT WHY
DO I URGE YOU TO
CHOOSE THESE COURTS.  AS MY
COLLEAGUES AND BATTLE BUDDY AND
MY TEAMMATE MELISSA SAYS, THEY
WORK.  THE BATTLE IS SHOWING
ANECDOTALLY SOMETIMES.  SUPPORT
FROM VETERANS IMPROVES OUTCOMES
DRAMATICALLY FOR OUR
JUSTICE-INVOLVED VETERANS.  AND
IMPORTANTLY, THESE COURTS
RESTORE HOPE.  THEY UNLOCK
POTENTIAL AND THEY PROMOTE A
LIFESTYLE OF RECOVERY.  AND AS A
NATION, ARE WE REALLY GOING TO
CHOOSE ANYTHING LESS FOR OUR
VETERANS?  I HOPE NOT.  I AM
GRATEFUL FOR OUR PANELISTS TODAY
AND THE INFORMATION YOU'RE
ABOUT TO GET FROM THEM WHO WILL
GIVE UP THEIR TIME AND EXPERTISE
TO HELP US BETTER UNDERSTAND
AND THUS TREAT ONE OF THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES FACING SOME OF OUR
VETERANS AND THAT IS PTSD.
THE MORE WE KNOW AND THE MORE WE
UNDERSTAND, THE MORE LIVES WE
CAN CHANGE AND THE MORE LIVES WE
CAN SAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE].
VIDEO FROM THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE VETERANS LIFE BROAD
CAST ON TREATMENT COURTS, I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS
VIDEO WILL HIGHLIGHT THE
STRUGGLES THAT SOME OF OUR
VETERANS FACE.  I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US TO
REMEMBER AS WE WATCH THE VIDEO
AND THROUGHOUT TODAY'S
CONVERSATION, AS SAID BEFORE,
THE VAST MAJORITY OF VETERANS
ARE STRENGTHENED BY THE MILITARY
SERVICE AND RETURNING HOME
TRULY
AS CIVIC ASSETS.  AND ALL OF
THE CHARACTERISTICS THAT OUR
VETERANS SHARE, INCLUDING THE
ONES THAT ARE STRUGGLING, IS
RESILIENCE.  GIVING THE
STRUCTURE, THE TREATMENT AND THE
MENTORING IN VETERANS TREATMENT
COURT, THE VETERANS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THESE PROGRAMS
THRIVE.  THEY, TOO, RETURN HOME
TO OUR COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY
ARE VALUABLE VALUABLE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, LEADERS AND
CIVIC ASSETS, WHAT HAS BEEN
REMARKABLE TO SEE OVER THE PAST
THREE AND A HALF YEARS AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND GETTING TO KNOW
THE MEN THAT PARTICIPATE IN THE
VETERANS COURT PROGRAMS, THEY
ARE THE FINEST MEN AND WOMEN
THAT I HAVE EVER ENCOUNTERED.  I
AM HUMBLED TO KNOW THEM AND
WATCH ON THEIR BEHALF AND
WATCHING HOW GRATEFUL THEY ARE
FOR THE SECOND CHANCE AND HOW
COMMITTED THEY ARE TO GIVING
BACK, PROVES TO ALL OF US EVERY
DAY WHY THESE PROGRAMS ARE SO
GREATLY NEEDED, THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  I SUFFER FROM GREAT
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY.  AND I
FELT LIKE I WAS ALL ALONG WITH
WHAT I AM DEALING WITH, MY
SITUATION.  JUST BUMMED OUT.  NO
PLACE TO GO.  REALLY, REALLY
DEPRESSED.  REAL DEEP
DEPRESSION.
SPEAKER:  I WANTED EVERYTHING TO
END.  I WANTED TO GET REVENGE.
I WANTED TO DIE.
SPEAKER:  I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
PTSD AND OTHER DISORDERS.  I
HAVE SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND
SUICIDAL ATTEMPTS.  I GOT
ARRESTED FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
TWO ASSAULTS.  AND I ENDED UP
ATTACHING MY FIRST CASE, MY
FIRST LEGAL CASE THAT I WAS
LOOKING AT IN PRISON.
SPEAKER:  WHEN I RETURNED HOME
FROM VIETNAM IN 1968 I HAD NO
IDEA WHAT POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS
DISORDER WAS.  EVERYTHING WAS
NORMAL.
SPEAKER:  I GOT HIM TO DRINKING
AND THE STUFF THAT GOES WITH
THAT, KIND OF ACTING OUT.
SPEAKER:  I WAS ADDICTED TO
DRUGS.  I WAS DRINKING A LOT.  I
WAS MAKING BAD DECISIONS.  AND
BASICALLY IT ALL CAUGHT
UP WITH ME.
SPEAKER:  IT PRETTY MUCH
SPIRALLED OUT OF CONTROL.  AND
MY LOWEST POINT WAS, I WAS
HOMELESS.  I LIVED IN MY TRUCK
FOR THREE MONTHS.  AND I GOT A
THIRD DUI AND I ENDED UP IN
JAIL.
SPEAKER:  I TOLD PEOPLE THE
HARDEST PART ABOUT GOING THERE
IS GOING HOME.  AND EVERYBODY
CHANGES OVER THE COURSE OF BEING
GONE.  I FELT LIKE A STRANGER
COMING BACK.
SPEAKER:  THE FRIENDS THAT YOU
MAKE IN THE CIVILIAN WORLD,
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE REALLY GREAT
FRIENDS, THEY'RE NOT LIKE THE
FRIENDS YOU HAVE IN THE MARINE
CORE.  WHEN YOU'RE IN THE MARINE
CORE, IT'S A SISTER HOOD AND A
BROTHERHOOD.
SPEAKER:  ONE OF MY REALLY GOOD
FRIENDS WAS KILLED.  IT REALLY
DEVASTATED ME.  I WANTED NOTHING
TO DO WITH EVERYBODY.  BUT GO
DRINK.
SPEAKER:  THERE WAS A YOUNG
GIRL, 15 OR 17 YEARS OLD.  AND
SHE WAS A CASHIER.  AND I SAW
HER, IN MY MIND, WEARING A
BIRKA.
INSTANTLY I WANTED TO PUNCH
HER.  AND I REMEMBER TAPPING MY
FOOT LEFT AND RIGHT THINKING I'M
NOT IN ANOTHER
COUNTRY.
SPEAKER:  GOOD AFTERNOON.  I'M
JONATHAN ELIAS.  NEWS ANCHOR
OVER AT ABC7 NEWS HERE IN TOWN
WHICH I HOPE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
YOU WATCH.  I'M ALSO A ADJUNCT
PROFESSOR  AT THE U.S. ARMY WAR
COLLEGE.  IT STARTED 12 YEARS
AGO WHEN I STARTED A WELCOME
HOME PROJECT AND IT WAS A SIMPLE
THING AND IN MY MIND I THOUGHT
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT I WANTED
TO DO AND I WANTED TO GIVE A
HANDSHAKE AND A HUG TO VETERANS
RECEIVING A PURPLE HEART.  GOOD
TO HAVE YOU HOME.  WE LOVE YOU.
YOU ARE VALUED.  I WAS A HISTORY
STUDENT IN COLLEGE AFTER WORLD
WAR II.  THEY DIDN'T CALL IT
PTSD AT THAT TIME.  THEY SMOKED,
THEY DRANKED.  THEY ARE
ESCAPIST.  I REMEMBER THERE WAS
A YOUNG GOOD LOOKING
CORPSMAN AND HE SAID WHY ARE
YOU DOING THIS AND HE SHAKED AND
HUGGED ME IN MY ARMS.  HERE I
AM CELEBRATING THESE SPIRITS
THAT HAVE SEEMED TO BE UNTOUCHED
AND UNBROKEN BY WAR, THEY WERE
NOT ONLY BEING TOUCHED BUT BEING
SHATTERED.  IT HAS TO BE
EMPHASIZED, IT WAS SOME.  THERE
IS A STORY.  AND IT NEEDS TO BE
TOLD AND IT'S OUR PROBLEM TO
FIX.  THESE ARE OUR WARRIORS TO
GO PROTECT OUR FREEDOMS.  THE
LEAST WE CAN DO IS FIGURE IT
OUT.  THE BEST I CAN TELL FROM
TALKING TO VETERANS, IF YOU HAVE
NEVER EXPERIENCED COMBAT, IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOU TRULY TO
UNDERSTAND IT.  AND HE WAS WITH
THE UNIT AND INFANTRY.  HE SAID
WITHIN A FIVE-MINUTE PERIOD IN
MY LIFETIME, I WALKED INTO A
SITUATION AND I REMEMBER
SMELLING GUN SMOKE AND GUN
POWDER AND SEEING THREE OF MY
FRIENDS DEAD ON THE GROUND.  OR
AT LEAST PIECES OF THEM.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU TRANSLATE
THAT TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER
EXPERIENCED COMBAT AND EXPECT
THEM TO COME HOME AND OBEY A
TRAFFIC LIGHT AND HAVE BASEBALL
GAMES IN THE BACKGROUND.  THOSE
ARE THE THINGS THAT ARE
DIFFICULT, IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE, TO
TRANSITION.  THAT REALLY IS THE
GOAL.  HAVING RESOURCES AND
EXPERTS LIKE YOU SEE HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS GETTING THE
CONVERSATION GOING.  THEY HAVE
BEEN HAVING THE CONVERSATION A
LONG TIME.  PERHAPS THE AUDIENCE
WHO IS POLICY MAKERS AND CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS, WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH SOMETHING TODAY.
LET'S START WITH INTRODUCING THE
PANEL.  I WILL HAVE YOU
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.  TELL YOU
THEIR NAME AND WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.  GREG, LET'S START WITH
YOU.
SPEAKER:  HI I'M GREG CRAWFORD,
I'M A VETERAN OF THE U.S. AIR
FORCE AND CURRENTLY A
CORRECTIONAL PROGRAM SPECIALIST
AT THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
CORRECTIONS AND FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THOSE THAT HAVE SERVED OUR
COUNTRY AND MORE IMPORTANTLY,
SOME OF THOSE THAT HAVE
CONTINUED TO SERVE, SERVING AS
VOLUNTEER VETERANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.  WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SERVICE.  I ALSO WANT TO THANK
ANDREW HUBERT AND THE LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FOR GIVING US THIS
OPPORTUNITY.  JAKE TAPPER FOR
TAKING HIM OUT OF HIS DAY TO SEE
US.  AND
MELISSA FITZGERALD AND BUTCH.
AND JONATHAN, THANK YOU FOR
SERVING AS MODERATOR TODAY.
AND YOU WERE THE ONLY REPORTER
SITTING ON THE FINISH LINE AT
THE BOSTON MARATHON BOMBING.
AFTER MY SERVICE I WAS ABLE TO
GO ON TO COMPLETE MY BACHELOR'S
DEGREE AT WASHINGTON STATE
UNIVERSITY AND MY MASTER'S
DEGREE AT CHAPMAN UNIVERSITY.  I
STARTED MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER
IN MENTAL HEALTH AND WENT ON TO
SERVE 11 YEARS IN DISTRICT COURT
AS A PROBATION OFFICER AND
SUPERVISOR DIRECTOR AND MANAGER
OF ALTERNATIVE PROGRAMS.  AND I
CAME TO NIC IN 2012 AND SHORTLY
AFTER MY ARRIVAL, MY FORMER
SUPERVISOR AND FORMER DIRECTOR
SAYS, GREG, I WANT YOU TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT VETERANS AND HE
SENT ME TO THE CHAIR DR. TOM
BURGER AND I ATTENDED THAT
MEETING AND IN BETWEEN
PRESENTATIONS I CAME UP AND
INTRODUCED MYSELF.  WE GOT TO
TALKING.  AND HE SAID YOU GOT TO
MEET BERNIE EDELMAN AND THE
THREE OF US MET AT UNION STATION
AND STARTED SCRIBBLING
.  AND A FEW YEARS LATER WE
CREATED VETERANS TREATMENT
COURTS.  AND IN PUBLICATION,
SOME OF YOU MAYBE HAVE GOTTEN A
COPY OF, REALLY SERVED AS THE
PLATFORM INITIATIVE FOR NIC AND
I WOULD BE REMISED IF I DIDN'T
THANK THE VETERANS AND NIC DONNA
LEDBETTER WHO HAS TAKEN UP AN
INTEREST IN VETERANS INITIATIVE
AND RESPONSIBLE FOR CONNECTING
US TO ANDREW HUBERT AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING WHAT WE
ARE WORKING ON AT NIC AND WILL
PASS IT OVER TO BERNIE.
SPEAKER:  I'M BERNIE EDELMAN AND
I'M FROM BROOKLYN, NEW YORK.
GREW UP IN A PUBLIC HOUSING
PROJECT IN CANARSIE.  POLITELY
IS CALLED THE ARMPIT OF THE
BOROUGH.  IF MY HOUSING PROJECT
OF ABOUT 10,000 SOULS
WAS A LITTLE CITY, WE ARE
MOURNING THE DEATHS OF ABOUT TEN
GUYS IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA.  AND I GOT
DRAFTED AND SCRIPTED RIGHT AFTER
I GOT OUT OF COLLEGE.  AND
SPENT MOST OF 1970, HALF WAY
AROUND THE WORLD IN VIETNAM.
WHICH IS COMING BACK TO ME AND
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT I AM
DOING WHAT I AM DOING.  AND I
PARTICIPATED IN THE SHOW IN ST.
PAUL MINNESOTA.
AND BROUGHT THE SHOW TO NEW YORK
CITY.  AND
GIVE A PIECE OF THE MAGAZINE.
WE HAVE 1500 PEOPLE ON OPENING
NIGHT.  650 A DAY COMING IN
TO SEE THIS STUFF.
AND 15% OF THE WORK SOLD.  AND
MY APPOINTMENT ED COCH, FIRST
PUBLIC ELECTED OFFICIAL TO PUT
HIS MONEY WHERE HIS MOUTH WAS
AND ACTUALLY HELP VIETNAM
VETERANS.  AND I KNOW I OWE HIM
A DEBT OF GRATITUDE.  AND ON THE
NEW YORK VIETNAM VETERANS
MEMORIAL COMMISSION I SERVED ON
A COMMITTEE THAT CHOSE DESIGN
FOR THE MEMORIAL, AND THAT
WAS THE BASIS FOR THE BOOK
WHICH I DID IN ABOUT TEN WEEKS,
WITH SEVEN OR EIGHT WEEKS OF
FINE TUNING.  DID IT FOR THE
COMMISSION, HBO DID A FILM
BASED ON THIS BOOK.  AND TWO OF
THE FIRST THREE
EMMY EVER.  AND HAD AN ACADEMY
AWARD.  AND MEANWHILE I WAS
NAMED THE FIRST DIRECTOR IN THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE FROM VETERANS
AFFAIRS IN THE CITY OF NEW YORK.
THAT'S UNTIL ED LEFT HIS JOB
AND
BERNIE LEFT HIS.
AND I DID SOME OTHER THINGS AND
VIETNAM KEEPS COMING BACK.
I'M A WRITER, A PHOTOGRAPHER, AN
EDITOR AND I HAVE DONE A COUPLE
OF OTHER BOOKS AND I CONSIDER A
SECOND CHANCE
TO BE ONE OF THE BOOKS.  WHEN I
MET GREG AND HE ASKED ME TO DO
SOMETHING, I THINK HE WAS
THINKING OF, YOU KNOW, 16 PAGE
BROCHURE, SHORT BOOKLET ABOUT
HOW TO DEAL WITH VETERANS
TREATMENT CORE.  I TOLD HIM I
WOULD DO SOMETHING UNLIKE ANY
GOVERNMENT PUBLICATION.  AND I
THINK WE HAVE SUCCEEDED ON THAT.
I GAVE HIM 40,000 WORDS AND A
LOT OF IT WOULD BE WORDS OF THE
FOLKS WE SPOKE WITH TOGETHER.
DR. BURGER, MYSELF, GREG.  IT
WAS AN EXPERIENCE.  I WAS SO
IMPRESSED,
SO TAKEN BY THE SENSE OF
COMMITMENT.  THE ELEGANCE OF THE
FOLKS WE SPOKE WITH, WHETHER
THEY WERE GRADUATES OF THE
VETERANS TREATMENT COURT OR
WORKED IN THE VETERANS TREATMENT
COURT.  AND THEY TOLD THE
STORIES BEAUTIFULLY.  AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT STUCK WITH ME.
NIC DESERVES ALL OF THE CREDIT
IN THE WORLD FOR DOING A LOT OF
STUFF TO HELP JUSTICE-INVOLVED
VETERANS.  THEY FORMED THE
JUSTICE-INVOLVED VETERANS
NETWORK.  FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE
FIELD AND MYSELF SERVE ON IT.
AND WE HOPE TO DO THINGS THAT
WILL AFFECT POLICY.
NOT ONLY ON A NATIONAL LEVEL,
BUT FROM STATE
TO STATE TO STATE.  BECAUSE
VETERANS TODAY CHOOSE TO SERVE
IN THE MILITARY.
NO LONGER IS ANYONE CONSCRIPTED.
IT'S NOT AN ACCIDENT OF BIRTH
THAT YOU SERVE IN THE MILITARY.
WE OWE SOMETHING TO THOSE WHO
SERVE.  AND IF THEY GET IN
TROUBLE WITH THE LAW, AND GET
CAUGHT UP AND THE GREAT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM, WE HAVE TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO HELP THEM
DIVERT FROM IMPRISONMENT, HELP
THEM GET THEIR LIVES TOGETHER,
IF THEY ARE IMPRISONED.  HELP
THEM WHEN THEY GET OUT WITH
MENTORS.  HELP THEM REACT TO THE
SOCIETY THAT A LOT OF FOLKS
FEEL HAS ABANDONED THEM.  AND
WITH THAT?
SPEAKER:  JUDGE?
SPEAKER:  I'M VANCE PETERSON.
I'M DISTRICT COURT JUDGE IN
SPOKANE AND I HAVE BEEN ON THE
BENCH FOR 26 YEARS AND DURING
THE COURSE OF THAT TIME I SERVED
29 YEARS ACTIVE RESERVE AND
GUARD.  UNLIKE BERNIE I WAS NOT
IN THE PROJECTS IN NEW YORK.  I
GREW UP IN A SMALL RANCH.  AND
AT THAT TIME I WANTED AN
EDUCATION BADLY.  OUR HIGH
SCHOOL HAD LOST 5 INDIVIDUALS IN
VIETNAM.  AND THAT WAS NOT A
CONSIDERATION OF COURSE WHEN YOU
ARE 18.  AND THE COURSE FOR ME
IS TO FOLLOW A LONG STANDING
FAMILY TRADITION OF ENLISTING IN
THE MARINE CORE WHICH EVERYBODY
IN MY FAMILY WAS.  OR ONE DAY I
GOT AN ENVELOPE FROM THE ARMY
SAYS CONGRATULATIONS, YOU HAVE A
FOUR-YEAR SCHOLARSHIP AND I
TOOK THAT OPPORTUNITY AND WENT
TO SCHOOL AT GONZOGA AND AFTER
THAT I SERVED FOUR YEARS ON
ACTIVE DUTY.  TWO AND A HALF TO
THREE YEARS IN THE INFANTRY AND
GOT INVOLVED WITH THE SPECIAL
FORCES AND WENT TO THE
QUALIFICATIONS COURSE AT RANGER
SCHOOL AND ENDED UP IN 28 YEARS
OF SERVICE IN 2003 AT THE AGE OF
50, BEING TOLD BY THE GUARD,
YOU'RE TOO OLD.  SO YOU'RE OUT.
SO I KIND OF JUST WENT BACK TO
BEING A JUDGE, WHICH IS WHAT I
WAS DOING FOR A LIVING ANYWAY.
ABOUT 2000, I THINK IT WAS THE
FALL OF 2009, WE STARTED SEEING,
ON OUR BENCH, AN INFLUX OF
PRIMARILY YOUNG MALES, AND SOME
YOUNG FEMALES WHO WERE COMING IN
REALLY WITH NO CRIMINAL HISTORY
AND NO BACKGROUND.  IT WAS MORE
OR LESS LIKELY NORMALLY SO WITH
"NORMAL
CRIMINALS" AND THERE WAS
MILITARY SERVANTS AND I NOTICED
THAT THEY WERE ALL VETERANS.  AT
THAT TIME I WAS RUNNING A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COURT AND I
RESEARCHED AND FOUND OUT WITH
JUDGE ROBERT RUSSEL, AN
INCREDIBLE MAN.  AND WE MODELLED
EVERYTHING WE DID AFTER HIM IN
SPOKANE COUNTY.  AND WE PUT
TOGETHER A VETERANS COURT.  AND
AFTER THE FIRST YEAR WE ARE
GETTING READY TO GO TO
GRADUATION.  WE'RE GOING TO
GRADUATE THE FIRST GUY.  WE ARE
VERY VERY EXCITED.  I WON'T GIVE
YOU HIS LAST NAME.  BUT SERVED
TWO TOURS WITH THE BATTALION IN
IRAQ AND DID TWO NATIONAL GUARD
TOURS WITH THE 161 INFANTRY AND
HE WAS A PSYCHOLOGY STUDENT AT
WSU.  SPOKANE WASHINGTON, ABOUT
60 MILES NORTH.  THE HIS BE
LOVED GIRLFRIEND THEN CALLED HIM
UP ONE DAY AND SAID I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO BREAK UP AND DID
WHAT ANY GUY WOULD HAVE DONE AT
THAT TIME.
DRANK WHISKEY AND DROVE ALL OF
THE WAY TO SPOKANE AND
PROFESSING HIS LOVE TO HIS
GIRLFRIEND.  AND TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS CAME UP
BEHIND HIM AND TURNED INTO THREE
FELONIES.  HE HAD TWO ASSAULTS
ON AN OFFICER AND HAD THE
BREAKING AND ENTERING LEAK INTO
THE APARTMENT AND WHEN THEY GOT
THERE THAT YEAR EARLIER, THEY
REDUCED THE FELONIES TO
MISDEMEANORS AND CARRIED THEM TO
DISMISSAL IF HE COMPLETED THE
PROGRAM.  AND HE DID COMPLETE
THE PROGRAM.  AS A MATTER OF
FACT HE REQUESTED TO GET OUT
EARLY BY ABOUT TWO WEEKS BECAUSE
HE HAD TO GO ON HIS FIFTH
DEPLOYMENT.  AND HE DEFINITELY
HAD PTSD BUT AT THAT TIME, HE
JUST WENT AHEAD ANYWAY.
WE GRADUATED HIM EARLY AND AT
THAT TIME MY PHONE RANG.  A
FRIEND OF MINE IN DC SAYS HEY,
YOU RETIRED.  YOU ARE 58.  HOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO TO
AFGHANISTAN FOR A YEAR.  AND I
SAID, I WOULD LIKE TO GO TO
COSTA RICA AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GO TO HAWAII AND IT WOULD BE FOR
THE AFGHAN UNIT.  AND I GAVE
HIM A YEAR.  I LEARNED MORE IN
THAT YEAR ABOUT PTSD AND THE
YOUNG PEOPLE FIGHTING THIS ARE
WA,
R.
AND EVERY DAY OF 26, ALL
NATIONAL GUARDS MAN, WITH AN
AVERAGE OF ABOUT TWO YEARS OF
COMBAT TOURS.  THAT'S HOW THEY
MADE THEIR LIVING.  ODDLY ENOUGH
WHEN I GOT INVITED TO THE UNIT,
ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS WAS THE
GUY THAT FIRST GRADUATED FROM
OUR CLASS AND I'M PROUD TO SAY
HE WAS MY GUARDIAN ANGEL IN THE
PAST TWO MONTHS IN AFGHANISTAN.
AND WITH THAT, GRADUATED 140
PEOPLE AND EVERYONE IS REQUIRED
TO READ A LETTER TO THE COURT
UPON GRADUATION.  20 OF THEM
INDICATED ON THE RECORD THEY
COULD HAVE COMMITTED SUICIDE,
BUT FOR THIS PROGRAM.  SO ITS
BEEN AN INCREDIBLE EVENT FOR ME
AND INCREDIBLE HONOR TO BE WITH
THIS PANEL AND BEING SANDWICHED
BETWEEN THESE TWO VIETNAM VETS,
I FEEL SOMEWHAT SMALL.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  ON TOM
BERGER.
SPEAKER:  DR. TOM BERGER.  I AM
THE SON OF TWO WORLD WAR II
VETS.  MY FATHER WAS WITH
CARLTON RADARS, A MARINE
BATTALION WHO WAS WOUNDED AND AT
THE TIME, MARINES SPENT THEM TO
THE BALBOA HOSPITAL, AND THIS
REDHEADED NURSE.  SO HERE I AM.
IN ANY CASE, I GREW UP IN A
FAMILY THAT WAS VERY IN TUNE TO
MILITARY SERVICE.  NOT ONLY MY
PARENTS.  MY GRAND PARENTS ON
BOTH SIDES SERVED IN WORLD WAR
ONE.  IN FACT MY PATERNAL
GRANDFATHER WAS A TANKER IN
WORLD WAR ONE AND GREW UP WITH A
PICTURE OF HIM STANDING OUTSIDE
THIS VEHICLE THAT LOOKED LIKE
THE MILLENNIUM FALCON.  ALL
RIGHT.  IT PROBABLY RAN THREE
MILES AND THEN IT BROKE DOWN.
BUT ANYWAY, SO IN 1965, I GOT A
LETTER FROM THE ARMY THAT SAYS
WE REQUEST YOUR PRESENCE.  SO
NOT KNOWING WHAT TO DO, I CALLED
MY DAD.  AND I SAID POPS, WHAT
DO I DO?  HE SAID, I DON'T WANT
YOU IN THE ARMY.  AND I DON'T
WANT YOU IN THE MARINES.
BECAUSE THEY ARE ALREADY OVER
THERE AND THEY ARE GETTING THEIR
ASS KICKED.  WHY DON'T YOU TRY
THE NAVY?  SO I FOUND OUT WHERE
THE NEAREST NAVY RECRUITER WAS
AND RAN OVER THERE AND JOINED.
AND JUST AFTER I RAISED MY HAND,
I RAN INTO A HIGH SCHOOL
CLASSMATE IN HIS UNIFORM, REALLY
LOOKED SHORP.
AND HE SAID TOM, ARE YOU STILL
GOING TO SCHOOL?
AND I SAID YEAH, I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH HOURS.  SO I GOT DRAFTED.
AND HE SAID WHAT IS YOUR MAJOR.
AND I SAID PRE-MED.  YOU OUGHT
TO SIGN UP TO BE A CORPSMAN.  I
JUST DID TWO YEARS AT MEMPHIS
NAVAL AIR STATION.  THERE WERE
WOMEN.  SKILLS THAT I LEARNED.
AND IT WAS COOL.  AND I RAN
RIGHT IN AND SIGNED UP TO GO TO
CORPSMAN SCHOOL AND WHEN I GOT
HOME, I THOUGHT MY FATHER WAS
GOING TO BEAT THE CRAP OUT OF
ME.  HE SAID, DO YOU KNOW WHAT
CORPSMAN DO?  I SAID NO, POPS.
THE HE SAID, THEY SERVE WITH THE
MARINES.  SO I SERVED WITH THE
MARINES IN VIETNAM.  OFF AND ON.
THIRD DIVISION, THIRD BATTALION
AND THIRD RECOMP.  GOT THE MAGIC
WOUND IN THE SPRING OF 1968 AT
CASON.  WHEN I CAME HOME,
THE COUNTRY WAS NUTS, I TRIED
TO BE AN EMT OR WHAT THEY CALL
EMTS NOW, BUT THERE WAS NO
COORDINATION AMONGST POLICE,
FIRE OR EMERGENCY
MEDICAL PEOPLE.  SO WE WENT
INTO A SITUATION IN ROCKSBURY,
MASSACHUSETTS.  AND I WENT BACK
TO BOSTON FOR THE LOVE OF A
WOMAN WHICH DIDN'T WORK OUT.
AND THEN GOT CALLED DOWN TO
PROJECTS FOR GUNSHOT WOUNDS ON
THE 7TH FLOOR WHILE THE
ELEVATORS WEREN'T WORKING AND WE
HAD TO TAKE A DOOR OFF AND PUT
THIS LARGE PERSON ON THE DOOR
AND TAKE HER DOWN SEVEN FLOORS
WHILE PEOPLE WERE SHOOTING.
AND I THOUGHT, YOU JUST CAME
BACK FROM TWO YEARS OF THIS
STUFF, AND YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHY
YOU WERE THERE.  NOW YOU ARE
HERE IN THE COUNTRY OF ORIGIN,
OKAY AND YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON HERE.  SO I FOOLED
AROUND A LITTLE ABOUT WITH
ANTIWAR GROUPS, SDS.  A COUPLE
OF OTHER GROUPS AND DECIDED THE
ONLY WAY I CAN DEAL WITH THINGS
WAS TO THROW MYSELF INTO
SCHOOL, WHICH I DID.
THAT'S HOW I
DEALT WITH MY STUFF,
PARTICIPATING IN WHAT WE CALL
RAP GROUPS.  WE MET IN THE
LIBRARY MEETING ROOMS, CHURCH
BASEMENTS AND BARS IN THE BACK
ROOMS WHERE WE TALK ABOUT OUR
COMMON EXPERIENCES.  THERE WERE
NO VET CENTERS AT THE TIME.  AND
IN FACT THE CURRENT VET CENTER
SYSTEM AS WE KNOW IT CAME OUT OF
VETS RAP GROUPS STARTED BY
VIETNAM VETS.  IN ANY CASE, I
JUST THREW MYSELF INTO SCHOOL
AND GOT MORE DEGREES THAN A
THERMOMETER.  POINT BEING,
THAT'S HOW I DEALT
WITH IT AND GOT INTERESTED.
AND THAT'S HOW I THOUGHT OF THEM
IN MY ACADEMIC WORK.  MY LAST
POSITION, I RAN A LITTLE CENTER,
RESEARCH CENTER, AND WE STUDY
HIGH RISK BEHAVIORS INCLUDING
SUICIDE, AND VIOLENCE.
SO THAT'S HOW I GOT FROM THERE
TO HERE.  I THINK THE COURTS ARE
A PHENOMENAL, PHENOMENAL
HAPPENING.  AND THE WORD
NEEDS TO BE SPREAD.  AS SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID VIA
THEIR EXPERIENCE.  IT'S
INCREDIBLE.
ONE STORY AND THEN I WILL
SHORTEN THINGS UP HERE.  AS PART
OF THE WHITE BOOK PROCEDURES, I
SPENT SOME TIME OUT ON THE WEST
COAST IN A VETERANS COURT OUT
THERE IN SANTA ANNA.  AND SO
SANTA ANNA WHERE THE COURTS ARE
LOCATED, IT'S NOT IN A VERY NICE
NEIGHBORHOOD.  IN FACT WHEN I
GOT THERE, THEY WANTED TO KNOW
IF I WANTED AN ESCORT BECAUSE I
WOULD COME IN AT LIKE 7:30 IN
THE MORNING AND NOT LEAVE UNTIL
7:30 IN THE EVENING DOING MY
INTERVIEWS AND STUFF.  THE MOST
IMPRESSIVE THING ABOUT IT WAS
THAT A NEW JUDGE HAD TAKEN OVER
IN THE VET COURT THERE.  AND HE
WAS TRYING TO FILL THE SHOES OF
SOMEONE WHO HAD BIG SHOES TO
FILL IN THE
VET TREATMENT COURT BUSINESS.
AND SO WHEN I WALKED INTO HIS
CHAMBERS, HERE ARE ALL OF THESE
BOOKS, WRITTEN BY
VETERANS, ABOUT VETERANS.  AND
I THOUGHT THIS WAS PRETTY
SCHOOL.  HE HAD SURROUNDED
HIMSELF WITH VETERANS AS PART OF
THE VETERAN TREATMENT COURT IN
SANTA ANNA.  AND THEN THE MOST
AMAZING THING HAPPENED, THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE DOCKET.
PEOPLE ON THE DOCKET FOR THE
DAY.  AND THE JUDGE LOOKED AT ME
AND HE SAID, DOC, WOULD YOU
MIND STAYING AROUND?
I THINK MAYBE WE WOULD LIKE YOUR
PROFESSIONAL OPINION.  I HAVE
SOME DEGREES IN MENTAL HEALTH.
SO I SAID, SURE.  AND I DID.
THIS IS THE VERY, VERY, VERY
SERIOUS CASE.  WE ARE TALKING
PY ROMANIA HERE.  NOT ONLY THE
INDIVIDUAL.  BUT EVERYTHING
AROUND HIM.  THE PERSON REALLY
NEEDED HELP.  SO THE DISCUSSION
FOCUSED ON HOW CAN WE BEST HELP
THIS PERSON?  HELP THIS PERSON.
THE WHO HAS THIS REALLY SERIOUS
PROBLEM CAUSED BY THIS PERSON
WHO HAS REALLY SERIOUS PROBLEMS.
TBI AND OTHER THINGS.  I THINK
IN MY HUMBLE OPINION, THEY DID
THE BEST THING THEY COULD.  AND
THAT IS, THEY PUT HIM IN
SUPERVISED LIVING CONDITIONS
WHERE HE WAS MONITORED.  IF HE
WOULD HAVE LIVED ON THE OUTSIDE,
HE DID WANT TO LIVE WITH HIS
SISTER.  AND IF HE HAD LIVED
WITH HIS SISTER AND BURNED THE
HOUSE DOWN, PERHAPS WOULD KILL
HER AND THE FAMILY AS WELL.  AND
I THOUGHT, WOW, WOW.
AND IT WAS THOROUGHLY DISCUSSED
BY ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COURT, THERE WAS NO ACRIMONY
INVOLVED AND HE HAD BURNED DOWN
HOUSES AND DONE THESE THINGS AND
WE NEED TO LOCK HIM UP.  IT WAS
AN AMAZING EVENT FOR ME.  SO I
THINK THE VET COURTS, AS I SAID
EARLIER, ARE THE BEST THING THAT
HAVE HAPPENED.
I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT SOME
FOLKS ARE DOING NOW.  LOOKING AT
WHEN FOLKS GET OUT OF THE
SYSTEM AND HOW WE GET THEM BACK
INTO LIFE.  BECAUSE PRISON IS A
DIFFERENT LIFE.  BUT IN ANY
CASE, IT'S THE BEST THING THAT
HAS HAPPENED TO VETERANS SINCE
THE VA WAS STARTED AND WE ALL
KNOW ABOUT THE VA.  BUT IN ANY
CASE, I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
THIS MARINE OVER HERE.
SPEAKER:  TIMOTHY WYNN.
SPEAKER:  MY NAME IS TIMOTHY
WYNN.  I'M FROM PHILADELPHIA AND
I SERVED IN THE GREATEST
FIGHTING FORCE KNOWN TO MAN
KIND, THE UNITED STATES MARINE
CORE.  I'M A LITTLE BIAS I
GUESS.
SPEAKER:  ALL OF THE ARMIES,
NAVY, COASTIES.
SPEAKER:  WE ROCK.
SPEAKER:  NO, BUT I HAVEN'T
WRITTEN A BOOK.  BUT AFTER
TODAY, I THINK I MAY BE WILLING
TO DO THAT.  I HAVE A STORY TO
TELL AND I AM LUCKY ENOUGH TO GO
AROUND AND TELL MY STORY.  I
GRADUATED FROM THE PHILADELPHIA
VETERANS COURT AND NOW I'M A
MENTOR IN THE SAME COURT THAT I
GRADUATED FROM.  I STICK AROUND
THERE BECAUSE THERE IS ALWAYS A
YOUNGER VERSION OF ME COMING
THROUGH THE DOOR EVERY WEEK.  I
LIKE TO HELP THEM.  I REMEMBER
WALKING THROUGH THE DOOR NOT
HAVING ANY HOPE.  AND PEOPLE
LEND IT TO ME.  SO I AM THERE TO
LEND HOPE TO THE VETERANS THAT
ARE COMING THROUGH.  I HAD SEVEN
ARRESTS BEFORE I ENDED UP IN
PHILADELPHIA VETERANS COURT.
WHEN I GOT INTO PHILADELPHIA
VETERANS COURT, THAT WAS MY LAST
ARREST.  I HAVEN'T BEEN
ARRESTED SINCE.  I'M WORKING ON
SEVEN YEARS CLEAN AND SOBER.  IT
HAS ABSOLUTELY CHANGED MY LIFE
AROUND, TO SAY THE LEAST.  I WAS
HOUSED IN THE PHILADELPHIA
COUNTY JAIL FOR A YEAR OF MY
LIFE DURING SEVERAL YEARS OF
ARREST.  AND ADDICTION AND
EVERYTHING ELSE.  AND I AM NOW
IN THAT PRISON ON MONDAYS AND
FRIDAYS, FACILITATING TRAUMA
GROUPS AND INMATES WHO ARE
LOCKED UP IN THAT SAME PRISON.
WHEN I WAS IN THAT PRISON, THERE
WAS NOBODY THERE.  I WAS KIND
OF BY MYSELF.  SOCIETY REALLY
WASN'T READY FOR THE VETERANS
THAT WERE COMING BACK FROM IRAQ
AND AFGHANISTAN.  IT WAS A
LONELY TIME IN MY LIFE.  I MAKE
SURE THAT I AM THERE FOR THE
VETERANS THERE BEHIND THAT WALL
EVERY DAY.  I TRY TO CONTINUE TO
DO THIS EVERY SINGLE DAY AND I
AM LUCKY TO BE HERE AND LUCKY
THAT I HAVE FRIENDS AT JUSTICE
FOR VETS.  AN ORGANIZATION THAT
I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT.  WHAT
THEY DO FOR VETERANS IN THIS
COUNTRY EVERY SINGLE DAY IT'S
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
SPEAKER:  GOOD TO HAVE ALL OF
YOU HERE.  GOOD TO POINT OUT, IF
YOU ARE NEW TO THE TERM PTSD OR
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKS,
IF YOU HAVE A COMMON COLD, THE
SYMPTOMS ARE EASY.  YOU HAVE A
FEVER, CHILL, YOU STAY IN BED
FOR A WEEK.  PTSD IS NOT SO
SIMPLE.  DOESN'T HAVE ANY KIND
OF SYMPTOMS THAT YOU NECESSARILY
CAN POINT TO.  IN ONE
INDIVIDUAL IT CAN BE SEVERE,
CHRONIC, DEBILITATING TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY CAN'T GET OUT
OF BED.  THE OTHER, FULLY
FUNCTIONING.  SO YOU CAN'T HAVE
A BLANKET TO TREAT PTSD.  I AM
SURE ALL OF YOU ON STAGE AGREE
WITH THAT AS WELL.  JUDGE, I
WANTED TO START WITH YOU.  YOU
TALK ABOUT IT IN A LITTLE BIT OF
THE INTRODUCTION.  IN MOST OF
THE CASES, WHAT PERCENTAGE WOULD
YOU ATTACH FOR THE FOLKS THAT
COME BEFORE YOUR BENCH AS
VETERANS, HOW MANY WOULD NOT BE
BEFORE YOU HAD THEY NOT
EXPERIENCED WHAT THEY DID IN
SERVICE?
SPEAKER:  I WOULD SAY AS MUCH AS
80%.  THESE FOLKS, THE PATTERN,
THERE IS A PROGRESSION THAT WE
SEE AS JUVENILES GO INTO ADULT
HOOD, THERE MIGHT BE LIGHTWEIGHT
THINGS.  AND IT COULD BE A
SERIES OF SPEEDING TICKETS.
RECKLESS DRIVING AND MAYBE A
MINOR ASSAULT AT SOME KIND.  BUT
THE PATTERN THAT WE SAW WASN'T
LIKE THAT AT ALL.  THE INSTANCES
GENERALLY OCCURRED AFTER THEIR
TOURS OF DUTY.  AND I WOULD
EASILY SAY 80% OF THEM WOULDN'T
BE IN FRONT OF US, DUE TO
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THEM IN THE
DEPLOYMENTS.
SPEAKER:  IN THE COURT AND
CORRECTIONS, THEY ALWAYS HAD A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH TO
VETERANS, THAT HAS CHANGED.
SPEAKER:  THAT HAS CHANGED.  I
WAS SURPRISED TO HEAR THE 3,000
MIDDLE, EXCUSE ME, DRUG COURTS
IN THE NATION TODAY.  I KNOW
THERE IS 330
VETERANS COURTS, MY PUSH IS TO
GET 3,000 VETERANS COURTS.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
THE CHANGE IS SUBSTANTIAL.  THE
VETERANS -- I DON'T WANT TO SAY
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT, BUT IT'S
GREATER THAN WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO DO, THAN IF
THEY JUST WENT TO WHAT I CALL
THE ALPHA COURTS.  THE STRAIGHT
CRIMINAL COURTS.  EACH DEFENDANT
THAT COMES BEFORE US, WE SPEND
ABOUT THREE TIMES AS MUCH TIME
ON INDIVIDUAL DEFENDANTS JUST
ENGAGING.  BECAUSE THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO PROCESS.  BUT THE
IDEA THROUGHOUT THE STAFF, WITH
THE MENTORS THAT WE HAVE, WITH
THE MENTOR COORDINATOR, AND THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT FOLKS, THE
IDEA IS TO GET THEM THROUGH THE
PROGRAM AND TO MAKE THEM
SUCCEED.  AND STARTED WHAT WE
CALL A HUMAN SALVAGE OPERATION.
UNLIKE THE COURTS WHERE IT'S
MORE PROCESSED.  AND YOU MIGHT
HAVE THREE CASES SET FOR TRIAL
AND EVERYBODY WILL SETTLE AND
EVERYBODY WILL HAVE AN AGREEMENT
IN TERMS OF THE SENTENCE AND
YOU ARE DONE IN TWO MINUTES.
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES OR MORE
FOR THE NEXT ONE AND YOU SPEND
A LOT MORE TIMES IN THE
VETERANS.
SPEAKER:  THE TIME THEY GET TO
YOU, IT'S TOO LATE.  A LOT OF
THE TIMES WHEN YOU ARE DEALING
WITH PTSD AS WE POINTED OUT,
IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL BY INDIVIDUAL
CASE BASIS.  IS THERE A SWITCH
INSIDE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT AT SOME POINT YOU
CAN GET TO OR HOPEFULLY GET TO,
TO FLIP THE SWITCH, AND THINGS
CAN BE PUT ON A PRODUCTIVE
PLANE?
SPEAKER:  I THINK SO, JONATHAN.
IF I CAN COME BACK A SECOND,
WHEN I WAS A PROBATION OFFICER,
UP THE STREET FROM JOINT BASE
LOUIS MCCORD, WE DIDN'T HAVE
VETERANS IMPROVEMENT COURTS AND
THERE WASN'T A LOT OF
PROGRAMMING IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE,
THE WARS IN AFGHANISTAN AND IRAQ
STARTED AND SOLDIERS STARTED TO
COME HOME AND WE STARTED TO SEE
A LARGE INFLUX LIKE YOU ALL DID
IN THE VETERANS SYSTEM AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE TREATMENT COURTS AND
I WAS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OFFICER AND THEY WERE THERE FOR
THE VIOLENCE CHARGE AND WE
DIDN'T TOUCH THE UNDER LYING
ISSUES.
SPEAKER:  THE VAST MAJORITY
CASES THAT YOU COME BACK INTO
THE SYSTEM ARE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE?
SPEAKER:  AT LEAST ON MY WORK
LOAD.  THEY SIT BEFORE ME
BROKEN.  WAITING TO BE
DISCHARGED, HONORABLE,
DISHONORABLE, THAT WAS BEFORE
VETERANS TREATMENT COURTS AND
SINCE 2008, WE HAVE 330 SINCE
NEARLY 100 IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION,
WATCHING FIRE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.  AND DIGGING DEEP
BESIDES THE CHARGE AT HAND.  AND
TALKED ABOUT THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO
TREATING VETERANS.
AND I HAVE A COLLEAGUE, I WON'T
SAY HIS NAME.  BUT AFTER A
COUPLE OF MONTHS HE WAS IN
DENIAL ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
COMMITTING TO A VETERANS
TREATMENT COURT.  AND AFTER A
WHILE, HE JUST CLICKED AND FELT
HE HAD A SENSE OF PURPOSE BACK.
AND I THINK THE VETERANS
TREATMENT COURTS HAVE UNDER
LYING ISSUES AND AT SOME POINT,
THE VALUE OF THE MENTOR AND
HELPING TO WALK THEM THROUGH THE
SYSTEM AND PROVIDING THAT, AT
SOME POINT THEY GET IT.
SPEAKER:  TIM, YOU WOULD BE THE
BEST ONE TO ANSWER THE QUESTION,
TOO.  YOU CAME THROUGH THE
PROGRAM.  AT WHAT POINT DID THAT
SWITCH GO OFF FOR YOU?  WHERE
YOU REALIZED THAT YOU KNOW WHAT,
THAT IS NOT THE LIFE THAT I
WANT TO LEAD.  WHEN DID THE
SWITCH GO OFF?  WHEN DID THE
RESOURCE BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
YOU?
SPEAKER:  I THINK THE CHANGING
MOMENT FOR ME WAS WHEN I WAS
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH UNIT IN
PRISON.  AND THEY KEPT GIVING ME
MEDICATION AND I WAS JUST DONE
WITH MEDICATION AT THIS POINT.
I HAD GOTTEN SO MUCH FROM THE VA
AND I JUST ABUSED THEM AND
TIRED OF FEELING LIKE THAT.  AND
I FELT VULNERABLE AND DIDN'T
WANT TO TAKE MORE PILLS.  I WAS
ARGUING WITH A LADY.  AND THE
DOOR SLOWLY SLID OPEN AND IN
WALKS A MAN, WHO I HAD NO IDEA
WHO HE WAS.
HE SAYS TO THE LADY, AND SHE
GOT UP, LEFT, AND SAT DOWN.
WASN'T A THERAPIST.
AND WASN'T LICENSED TO TREATMENT
PTSD OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHAT HE WAS IS A VIETNAM
VETERAN.  AND THAT'S THE FIRST
TIME I WAS INTRODUCED TO PEER TO
PEER SUPPORT.  I WILL NEVER
FORGET WHAT HE SAID TO ME.  THAT
PERSON YOU WERE BEFORE YOU LEFT
IS GONE FOREVER.  YOU'RE NEVER
COMING BACK.  AND YOU'RE A
CHANGED PERSON AND YOU NEED TO
FIND A DIFFERENT WAY TO COMBAT
THIS.  I THINK THE FIRST TIME I
HEARD THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME I
REALIZED I HAD A SURRENDER TO
WIN.  SURRENDER IS NOT IN OUR
VOCABULARY.  BUT IT'S VERY HARD
THING TO ACCEPT.  AND FROM THAT
POINT ON, I STARTED TO TURN MY
LIFE AROUND.
SPEAKER:  IS THERE ANY PART OF
YOU WITH COMBAT THAT YOU FEEL
COME ALIVE?  I SAW THAT VIDEO.
MENT IT'S LIKE ALL MY FRIENDS
HAVE CHANGEDED AND WE'RE ALL
SITTING IN THE ROOM AS EDUCATED
FOLKS.  NO, NO, NO.  YOU
CHANGED.  THOSE WHO LEAVE ARE
THE ONES THAT EVOLVE OR CHANGE
OR ARE DIFFERENT AND THEY EXPECT
EVERYTHING TO BE THE SAME.  BUT
THEY'RE NOT.
SPEAKER:  IT'S DEFINITELY NOT
THE SAME.  I REMEMBER NOT BEING
ABLE TO COME HOME AND TALK TO
EVERYBODY.  AND I CAN'T TALK TO
MY OWN MOTHER.  I CAN'T TALK TO
MY NEXT DOOR NEIGHBOR.
SPEAKER:  BECAUSE THEY JUST
WOULDN'T UNDERSTAND?
SPEAKER:  YEAH.  IT'S JUST NOT
THEIR FAULT THAT THEY WOULDN'T
UNDERSTAND.  THAT'S OKAY.
THAT'S WHY I THINK PEER TO PEER
SUPPORT IS SO IMPORTANT WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS.  HOW DOC TALKED
ABOUT SITTING IN THOSE RAP
GROUPS.  MYSELF AND MY FRIENDS
SITTING HERE TODAY, WE HAVE OUR
OWN RAP GROUPS EVERY MONDAY
NIGHT WITH COMMUNITY WITH
VETERANS AND.
SPEAKER:  AND
YOU CAME BACK FROM THE WAR.
THEY GET A TREATMENT.  A RED
CARPET TREATMENT, IF YOU WILL.
LET'S FACE IT.  THE MILITARY
DOES A LOT OF THINGS RIGHT.  AND
WHAT THEY ARE NOT GOOD AT IS
TRANSITIONING WARRIOR BASED
ETHOS INTO A CIVILIAN BASED
ETHOS.  THAT'S LIKE JUMPING FROM
A NASCAR IN THE FAST LANE TO A
PRIUS AT 10 MILES AN HOUR.  AND
DOC, I WANT TO BRING YOU BACK
IN.  YOU CAME BACK FROM AN
UNPOPULAR WAR WHERE YOU HAD TO
BURY THAT YOU SERVED, OR AT
LEAST PROTECT THE FACT THAT YOU
DID.
SPEAKER:  SURE.  I CAME BACK AND
I WAS IN ST. LOUIS AIRPORT.
AND I'M HONORED AS A NAVY
CORPSMAN.
I CAN WEAR THE MARINE GREEN
UNIFORM.  THERE IS A SPECIAL
BAND ON THE SLEEVES THAT
DISTINGUISHES ME AS A CORPSMAN.
I HAD MY MEDALS ON AND MY
RIBBONS ON AND WENT UP TO THE
BAR IN THE AIRPORT AND ORDERED A
DRINK AND HAD A FEW ON THE
AIRPLANE.  AND THERE IS A GUY
THAT LOOKS AT MY UNIFORM.  AND
HE SAYS HOW MANY BABIES DID YOU
KILL?  AND BEFORE I CAN HIT HIM
WITH THE BEER BOTTLE, THE
BARTENDER THE GUY AND THREW HIM
OUT OF THE BAR.  THIS IS MY
FIRST EXPERIENCE COMING BACK.
THE GUY WAS PROBABLY SLOSHED AND
THE WHOLE BUSINESS.
BUT THAT IS MY REACTION.  AND
THEN NOT BEING ABLE TO GO PLACES
IN UNIFORM BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
LET'S SAY REALLY RUDE TO YOU.
WITH LANGUAGE WE DIDN'T EVEN USE
IN THE CORE.  OKAY.  BUT TIM IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.  WHEN YOU COME
BACK, IT'S SO DIFFERENT.  IT'S
SO DIFFERENT.  AND NOBODY KNOWS
HOW TO DEAL WITH YOU.  BECAUSE
OF IT.  I APPRECIATE THE
COUNTRY HOW IT VALUES
ITS VETERANS.  BUT THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND, WAR CHANGES PEOPLE.
IT CHANGES PEOPLE.  SO IT'S
NOT JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.  IT'S WELCOME HOME.
AND THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN
THOSE TWO
PHRASES.
SPEAKER:  WELL TWO YEARS AGO I
WENT TO THE FIRST REUNION OF MY
FRATERNITY FROM COLLEGE IN 50
YEARS.  A REALLY NICE RESTAURANT
IN NEW YORK CITY IN MANHATTAN.
AND THESE ARE GOOD GUYS.  GUYS
THAT I WAS FRIENDS WITH.
THEY'RE LAWYERS.  THEY'RE
DOCTORS, DENTISTS, COLLEGE
PROFESSORS AND IN THE '50S,
THERE WERE FOUR OF US WHO SERVED
IN SOME CAPACITY IN THE
MILITARY.  ONE FRIEND OF MINE
WAS IN THE NATIONAL GUARD.
ANOTHER GUY, HE WAS IN THE
BRAVO.  AND THEY DIDN'T SEND HIM
TO VIETNAM.  THEY SEND HIM TO
GERMANY.  THE THIRD GUY DID NOT
WANT TO GET DRAFTED.  HE THOUGHT
HE WAS SMART AND JOINED THE AIR
FORCE AND WOUND UP IN THAILAND
WHERE HE LOST HIS BEST FRIEND
AND LOST A LOT OF
OTHER GUYS.
AND IT'S --
THERE WAS, TO ME, AND THERE WAS
A BARRIER IN THE WAY BETWEEN ME
AND THE FELLOWS.
AND THE PEOPLE MOST COMFORTABLE
AROUND, OUR VETERANS.  AND I
KNOW WHEN I CAME HOME, IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU DIDN'T
NECESSARILY TALK ABOUT.  BUT I
WAS LIKE DOC, A LITTLE BIT ANGRY
AT WHAT HAD BEEN GOING ON.  I
WAS THERE IN 1970.  WE WERE
DOING THE SO-CALLED PHASED
WITHDRAWAL.  I COULDN'T SEE
LOGICALLY WHY AMERICAN TROOPS
WERE STILL GOING OUT ON COMBAT
MISSIONS AND DYING.  SO I
PROTESTED THE WAR.  AND CAME
DOWN HERE IN THE BIG ANTIWAR
DEMONSTRATION CALLED DEWEY
CANYON THREE.  AND IT WAS THE
FIRST TIME SINCE THE BONUS SINCE
1932 I BELIEVE IT WAS, WHO CAME
TO WASHINGTON TO LOOK IT UP.
AND GET OUT OF VIETNAM NOW.  AND
I THINK IT HAD AN AFFECT, I
CERTAINLY HOPE
IT HAD AN AFFECT BUT IT WAS
CERTAINLY IN ME.  AND A LOT OF
OTHER FOLKS, THE SENSE OF ALIEN
ATION.  I WAS THERE.  I HAD TOP
SECRET CLEARANCE AND CAN TRAVEL
AROUND.  IN A PLACE CALLED
SCHULI WITH A PLACE WITH DOCTORS
AND NURSES.  AS MUCH OF THE
BASEMENT AND THE DEBRIS OF
WAR, AS MOST DID.  AND AS DOC
SAID, IT CHANGES YOU.  AND
UNLESS YOU'RE THERE, YOU CAN'T
UNDERSTAND.  EVEN IF YOU WATCH
THE BEST WAR MOVIES THAT WERE
EVER MADE.
SPEAKER:  LET'S TALK ABOUT FOR A
SECOND DEMONSTRATING THE TAIL
TELL SCIENCE
OF PTSD.  FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING, ALCOHOL, DRUG
USE, THOSE ARE ABOUT AS COMMON
ACROSS THE BOARD TELLTALE SIGNS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
ESCAPISM.  MAYBE NOT BEING ABLE
TO SOCIALIZE.  THEY WERE IN A
SOCIAL SETTING, MAYBE PERHAPS IN
THEIR HOMETOWN AND WITH THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL BUDDIES AND YACKING
ABOUT A FOOTBALL GAME.  MAYBE
THEY DON'T CONTRIBUTE.  AND GIVE
SOME OTHER TELLTALE SIGNS FOR
ANYBODY WATCHING IN THE AUDIENCE
OR MAYBE HAVE A LOVED ONE GOING
THROUGH THIS.  AND AT LEAST
WHAT ARE THEY UP AGAINST?
SPEAKER:  I WILL BET EVERY
COMBAT VET IN THIS ROOM KNOWS
EXACTLY WHAT I AM TALKING ABOUT.
IT HAPPENED TO ME THIS MORNING,
A COLLEAGUE.  NOW I PLACE MY
DESK SO IT FACES THE DOOR.  NOW
MOST, YOU KNOW, OFFICE
MANAGEMENT THINGS SAYS WELL,
THAT'S KIND OF -- PUT IT TO THE
SIDE OR WHATEVER.  THE I CAN'T
DO THAT BECAUSE EVEN WITH MY
DESK FACING THE DOORWAY.  IF I
AM FOCUSED ON READING SOMETHING
OR WHATEVER AND SOMEBODY JUST
SAYS HI DOC, IT SCARES THE YOU
KNOW WHAT OUT OF ME.  AND THAT
CAN HAPPEN ANYWHERE.  IF I AM
FOCUSED ON SOMETHING AND PEOPLE
CALL MY NAME OR I HEAR A LOUD
NOISE, SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THAT IS CERTAINLY A PROBLEM.
THE OTHER THING HAS BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE
CONVERSATION, NIGHTMARES AND
FLASHBACKS.  AND THOSE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS.  OKAY.  YOU
HAVE NIGHTMARES WHEN YOU SLEEP
AT NIGHT.  AND THEY
MAY BE THE SAME NIGHTMARE.
FLASHBACKS HAPPEN ANY TIME AND
YOU ARE BACK THERE.  BECAUSE
TRAUMA IS, AND PARTICULARLY
SEVERE TRAUMA CAN CHANGE THE
CIRCUITRY OF THE BRAIN SO THAT
CERTAIN, YOU WANT TO CALL THEM
TRIGGERS, WILL PUT YOU RIGHT
BACK WHERE A PARTICULAR
TRAUMATIC EVENT OCCURRED.  SO
THOSE ARE A COUPLE OF OTHERS.
SPEAKER:  LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
42 YEARS SINCE WAR, HAS IT FREED
YOU?  OR IS IT RIGHT AT THE
FOREFRONT AS IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN?
SPEAKER:  I DON'T WANT TO GO
BACK TO VIETNAM.  DESPITE ALL OF
THE OVERTURES IN FRIENDSHIP.
VIETNAM VETERANS OF AMERICA
WHERE I WORK HAS LED THE WAY.
WE HAVE A VETERANS INITIATIVE
WHICH WE CAN TALK ABOUT ANOTHER
TIME, ANOTHER PLACE.  I DON'T
WANT TO GO BACK THERE.  BECAUSE
I AM AFRAID THAT IT WILL BRING
BACK STUFF THAT I HAD TO DEAL
WITH, THROUGH THERAPY AND
THROUGH RAP GROUPS AND STUFF.
AND I DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH
THAT AGAIN.
BUT I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
RECURRING NIGHTMARES THAT I
CAN'T SEEM TO GET RID OF.  AND
THEY WERE PRETTY TRAUMATIC
SITUATIONS.  BUT THEY COME BACK.
AND IT'S USUALLY WHEN I AM
STRESSED OUT.  OKAY.
SPEAKER:  TIM?
SPEAKER:  I THINK ANGER IS A
MAIN ONE.  YOU KNOW.  SPEAKING
FOR MYSELF.
SPEAKER:  EXPLODE QUICKLY.
SPEAKER:  I OBVIOUSLY FOUND WAYS
TO COMBAT THAT, YOU KNOW,
THROUGH GROUP THERAPY AND STUFF
LIKE THAT.
SPEAKER:  NOW, LET ME ASK YOU
THIS, THE LOVED ONES AROUND YOU,
THAT'S THE WAY HE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN.  HAVE THEY TRIED TO
RATIONALIZE THE BEHAVIOR, RATHER
THAN TRYING TO COPE WITH IT?
SPEAKER:  THEY DIDN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND IT.  THEY KNEW THAT
SOMETHING WAS WRONG.  AND AGAIN
THEY DID NOT KNOW WHAT WAS
WRONG.  AND THEY DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT THEY WERE LOOKING AT AND
THEY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
FACING.  AND ANGER, I THINK IT
STEMS FROM, I CALL IT STANDING
IN THE SHALLOWS OF THE WAVES AND
THE OCEAN.  AND IT'S THE WAVE
OF EMOTIONS THAT KEEP COMING AND
YOU HAVE NEVER FELT THIS STUFF
BEFORE.  YOU GET ANGRY.  BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T NAVIGATE THROUGH THE
DAY AND CAN'T BE THAT SOCIAL
PERSON AND CAN'T GO HANG OUT
WITH THE GUYS AND TALK ABOUT THE
FOOTBALL GAME.  YOU WOULD
RATHER ISOLATE, THAT'S WHAT I
DID.  I WOULD USE DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL, THEY ARE 100% EFFECTIVE
EVERY TIME.  THEY NUMB IT.
SPEAKER:  AS A NATION, WE HAVE
BEEN AT WAR FOR 240 YEARS, A LOT
OF THE TIME, AND ALWAYS CALL IT
A SHELL SHOCK OR BEING QUIET
AND NOW WE HAVE IDENTIFIED PTSD
BECAUSE IT'S A PROBLEM AND THIS
IS A PROBLEM THAT HAS PLAYED THE
RETURNING WARRIORS SINCE WE
HAVE BEEN AT IT IN THE BATTLE
FIELD.
AND JUDGE, I AM CURIOUS OF WHAT
YOU HAVE SEEN.  I AM SURE YOU
HAVE TELLTALE SIGNS FROM A TO Z
ON THIS ONE.
SPEAKER:  SUBSTANCE ABUSE IS
REALLY THE REACTION.  UNDER
LYING OCCURRENCE IS THE ANGER.
AND GETTING READY TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN AT THE TIME, SOME OF
THE YOUNGER FOLKS, INFANTRY
TROOPERS, GOSH, WE WENT TO
AFGHANISTAN AND THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY WENT TO WALMART.  IT'S
ALMOST A RESENTMENT WHEN YOU GET
BACK.  AND OF COURSE ON THE
RETURN OF THE IRAQ AND AFGHAN
GUYS, IT'S MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
THE VIETNAM ERA.  YOU HEAR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE A LOT.  I
WAS ANGRY WHEN I GOT BACK.  THE
WAY THE ARMY HANDLED YOU.
SPEAKER:  LET ME ASK ALL OF YOU.
BECAUSE THE MILITARY SPENDS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
EVERYTHING, FROM PROTECTING
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTANDING THE WAR
AND UNDERSTANDING INTELLIGENCE,
IS THERE ANY KIND OF MECHANISM
THAT ANYONE CAN PROVIDE TO READY
THEM FOR EXPERIENCE?  I KNOW
THEY ARE TRAINED FOR COMBAT.
BUT TRAINING FOR COMBAT AND
LIVING THROUGH IT, TOTALLY
DIFFERENT THINGS.
SPEAKER:  SPOT ON WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.  THEY TRAIN YOU FOR
SITUATIONS THAT THREATEN YOU,
THAT PUTS YOU IN THE SENSE OF
DANGER AND YOU REACT.  AND IF
YOU FOLLOW THAT TRAINING,
CHANCES ARE YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE
IT THROUGH THAT SITUATION.
WHEN YOU COME HOME, OKAY: YOU
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE OLD WAY
OF THINKING,
WHICH IS, JUST BECAUSE PHYTO
POOPED ON THE FLOOR, THAT'S NOT
A LIFE THREATENING SITUATION.
BUT YOU REACT THAT WAY.  AND SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY SHOULD
CONSIDER IN MY HUMBLE OPINION,
AND CANADA DID IT FOR A WHILE
AND THE UK DID IT FOR A WHILE.
THEY PUT THEIR TROOPS IN SORT OF
A DECOMPRESSION.  AND I BELIEVE
IT WAS THE UK, THE CANADIANS
HAD A PLACE ON CYPHRUS AND IN
SOME CASES THERE WERE MARRIED
COUPLES AND STUFF.  GOOD.
AND THEY HELPED THEM DECOMPRESS.
THE SORT OF LIKE A POST SERVICE
BOOT CAMP.  NOW WHETHER THAT
WOULD GET A LOT OF SUPPORT DOWN
THE STREET OR NOT, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S NEITHER HERE OR THERE.
BUT WE COULD DO SOMETHING BETTER
ON THE END OF IT, TO GET US
BACK IN TERMS
OF THE TRANSITION SYSTEM.
SPEAKER:  SO YOU KNOW, I WORK
AND MY JOB IS REALLY TO IDENTIFY
THE GAPS BETWEEN CRIMINAL
JUSTICE TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
VETERANS AND ONE OF THE
INTERVIEWS THAT I WAS CONDUCTING
WITH A VETERAN, YOU KNOW,
TRAINED ME TO GET BASIC TRAINING
AND TRAINED ME TO GO TO THE
FIRST DUTY AND TRAINED ME TO GO
TO COMBAT AND DIDN'T TRAIN ME TO
COME HOME.  THAT'S A REAL GAP
IN OUR SYSTEM.  A COUPLE OF
POINTS, ONE, WE NEED TO REDUCE
THE STIGMA FOR SOLDIERS TO ASK
FOR HELP AND WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB HELPING THEM.  AND
WHY DOES THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY
TO CONVENE THEIR LIVES HAVE TO
DO WITH THE JUSTICE SYSTEM?  I
THINK THERE IS SPECIFIC FUNDING
IN DOD TO PAY FOR UNIFORMS AND
TRAVEL.
BUT THERE IS NO SPECIFIC FUNDING
TO COME HOME AND HELP THEM
ACCLIMATE HOME.  I THINK THAT'S
A REAL GAP THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
SPEAKER:  LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION.
SPEAKER:  I THINK THERE IS A
REAL PROBLEM ALSO.  THE MILITARY
HAS CHANGED.  ALTHOUGH IT IS
STILL AFFECTED IN A LOT OF WAYS
LIKE IT WAS IN WORLD WAR TWO, I
SAY THIS BECAUSE I HAVE GONE
CLINICAL WORK WITH DELTA FORCE
PEOPLE AND SEALS.  SOMEONE SAID
IT EARLIER.  MOST PERSONS DON'T
APPRECIATE THE TEMPLE OF
OPERATIONS OVER IN THE BIG
SANDBOX.  IT'S, I MEAN, HEAVY
DUTY INTENSE.
THE GENERAL AND MY COLLEAGUE
SITTING NEXT TO ME, THE JUDGE
WILL TELL YOU WHAT IT'S LIKE.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT THESE FOLKS ARE UNDER SUCH
INTENSE, PARTICULARLY IN OUR
SPECIAL OPS GROUPS.  UNDER SUCH
INTENSE PRESSURE THAT LIFE BACK
HERE IS NOT VERY REALISTIC TO
THEM WHEN THEY COME HOME.  THEY
TRY AND ADJUST.  OKAY.  BUT WHY
DO SO MANY OF OUR SPECIAL OPS
PEOPLE FEEL THAT THEY WERE MORE
AT HOME BACK THERE?
SPEAKER:  LET ME ASK THIS
QUESTION, TOO.  I KNOW WE LIVE
IN AN ADD SOCIETY.  AND I DON'T
MEAN TO USE THAT TERM.  BUT YOU
WILL SEE NINE OR TEN PEOPLE
WALKING AROUND TODAY WITH THEIR
PHONES.  THEY ARE CONNECTED TO I
DON'T KNOW WHAT.  A TEXT THAT
THEY CAN'T GO WITHOUT OR A
HEADLINE WHO THEY CAN'T GO
WITHOUT.  AND FOLKS IN COMBAT, I
HAVE HEARD THIS 99% OF THE
TIME, TIME STANDS STILL.  TIME
SLOWS DOWN.  THE CONTINUUM GOES
TO A GRINDING HALT.  AND WHEN
THEY COME HOME, THEY FEEL THE
RUNNING AROUND THEM 1,000 MILES
AN HOUR AND THEY ARE STUCK IN A
SPOT WHERE THEY NEED SOMEBODY TO
TALK TO.  LET'S GET INTO THE
RESOURCES.  WE HAVE THE
VETERANS COURTS THAT HAVE
SPREAD AND GROW A LOT MORE.
WHAT AVAILABLE RESOURCES ARE
THERE THAT VETERANS CAN REACH
OUT TO?  WE HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE
WATCHING ON TV AND PERHAPS
SITTING THERE SAYING, I DIDN'T
GET OUT OF BED UNTIL 11 THIS
MORNING AND I DIDN'T WANT TO GET
OUT OF BED.
WHAT ARE THE RESOURCES?
SPEAKER:  THERE ARE A LOT.  I
WOULD SAY FOR THOSE, BECAUSE WE
KNOW ALL OF THE MEDIA
SURROUNDING WITH THE VA, THEY
DON'T TRUST THE VA HOSPITALS FOR
WHATEVER REASON.  THE VET
CENTERS.
TRY THE VET CENTERS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE MOST CLASS
EFFICIENT MENTAL HEALTH
OPERATIONS IN THE VA SYSTEMS.
SPEAKER:  ALL THEY NEED TO DO IS
WALK IN AND SAY I NEED SOMEBODY
TO TALK TO.  YOU DON'T NEED TO
FILL OUT THE PAPERWORK AND GO
THROUGH RED TAPE.
SPEAKER:  YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
INFORMATION THAT YOU CHOOSE TO
SHARE AT A VET CENTER, DOESN'T
GO TO THE MOTHERSHIP, UNLESS YOU
SIGN A CONSENT.  AND FOR THOSE
VET CENTERS THAT HAVE THE
RESOURCES, MEANING THE MONEY AND
THE PEOPLE, THEY ALSO CAN WORK
WITH FAMILIES AND THAT'S A BIG
DEAL.  BECAUSE THE BIG HOSPITALS
AND STUFF AREN'T ALLOWED TO DO
THAT.  THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS.
BUT I HIGHLY RECOMMEND THE VET
CENTERS AND A LOT OF THE TEAM
LEADERS, WHAT THEY CALL THE VET
CENTERS, ARE COMBAT VETERANS
THEMSELVES AND THAT'S WHAT MADE
IT SUCH A SUCCESS.  THAT TEN
YEARS AGO, FIFTEEN YEARS AGO, I
GUESS NOW, BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
IN THIS LATEST MORASS FOR THAT
LONG, MOST OF THE LEADERS WERE
COMBAT VIETNAM VETERANS.
SPEAKER:  330 OR SO
VTC'S AT THE TREATMENT POSTS,
THERE ARE EXACTLY 300 VET
CENTERS LOCATED IN CITIES AND
STRIP MALLS.  IT SHOULD BE TWICE
THAT NUMBER AT LEAST. MENT
THAT'S WHEN RESOURCES NEED TO
GO.  BUT IT'S ALSO, WE DEPEND
UPON THE VA TO, AND THE
GOVERNMENT TO HELP THOSE WHO ARE
SEVERELY COMBAT WOUNDED TO HELP
THEM FISCALLY, PHYSICALLY,
SPIRITUAL LY
AND YOU HAVE TO DEPEND ON THE
COMMUNITY YOU LIVE IN.  STOP TO
THINK ABOUT THIS.  AFTER THE
SECOND WORLD WAR, WHEN THE
POPULATION OF THIS COUNTRY WAS
ABOUT 130 MILLION OR SO, 16
MILLION AMERICANS, MEN AND WOMEN
WERE IN UNIFORM.  JUST ABOUT
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY WAS
INVOLVED IN THE WAR EFFORTS.  I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE NUMBERS WERE
FOR KOREA.  IN VIETNAM HAD
SHRUNK TO SOMETHING LIKE 9%.
SOME PEOPLE SAID
4%.  RIGHT NOW, LESS THAN ONE
HALF OF 1% OF AMERICANS, AND
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
5-YEAR-OLD CHILDREN, BUT
AMERICANS I GUESS 18 OR ABOVE,
SERVE IN THE MILITARY.  THIS IS
A TINY NUMBER.  PEOPLE GO TO
COLLEGE AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT BEING DRAFTED OR
ANYTHING.
WHEN WE WERE IN SCHOOL, THAT
WAS, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT KEPT US IN SCHOOL, AS LONG
AS WE HAD THE GRADES.  BUT
PEOPLE COME HOME AND A LOT OF
TIMES THERE IS SOMETHING MISSING
IN COMMUNITY.  WHICH IS TRAGIC
AND IT REACHES TO MORE AREAS.
PEOPLE AREN'T WELCOMED HOME INTO
THE GRATEFUL NATION.  BECAUSE
TOO OFTEN THE NATION IS NOT
GRATEFUL FOR A WAR WITHOUT END.
AND THAT IS WHAT WE HAD IN
VIETNAM.  AND THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE NOW.
SPEAKER:  THE VETERANS CRISIS
LINE IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND GIVING
OUT THAT NUMBER.
SPEAKER:  THE VETERANS CRISIS
LINE,
1800-273-8255 AND WHEN YOU CALL
THAT NUMBER, JUST PRESS 1.
SPEAKER:  PRESS 1.  AND TIM, LET
ME GO TO YOU, YOU CAME BACK
FROM THIS WAR.  HOPE WAS THE
WORD THAT YOU USED.  THE
VETERANS THAT I TALKED TO IN
THIS WAR, THEY SEEM TO THINK
THAT THE PEOPLE AT HOME, WHILE
THEY ARE GRATEFUL FOR THEIR
SERVICE, THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE SERVICE WAS FOR.  AND
THEN THE TRANSLATION TO YOU WAS,
WHAT THE HELL AM I DOING?  IS
THAT A PART OF WHAT YOU
PROCESSED?  OR ARE STILL
PROCESSING?
SPEAKER:  I THINK FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME I WENT THROUGH
THAT.  NOT SO MUCH NOW.  TO ME
WHAT I DID OVER THERE WAS
STAYING SHOULDER TO SHOULDER
WITH MY BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
WE DID WHAT WE HAD TO DO TO GO
THROUGH EVERY SINGLE DAY TO
PROTECT ONE ANOTHER.  I DON'T
GET TOO FAR INTO IT POLITICAL,
WHY WE DID WHAT WE DID.  THAT'S
NOT MY CONCERN.  THEN WAS
PROTECTING THE PEOPLE TO THE
RIGHT AND LEFT OF ME.
SPEAKER:  DID YOU HAVE A CLEARLY
DEFINED OBJECTIVE AS A WARRIOR
IN BATTLE?  DID YOU UNDERSTAND
DAY TO DAY WHAT IT IS WHAT YOU
WERE TRYING TO DO OR ACCOMPLISH?
SPEAKER:  YES.  I HAD -- I WAS A
SERGEANT AND MY JOB WAS TO
PROTECT THE PEOPLE UNDERNEATH ME
AND THAT WAS MY MAIN OBJECTIVE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.  I WAS A 50
CAL GUNNER.  MY OBJECTIVE WAS TO
GET THE PEOPLE FROM POINT A TO
POINT B.  THAT WAS MY OBJECTIVE.
THERE ARE ALSO GOOD PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY OF IRAQ WHO NEED
PROTECTION.  AND WE PROTECTED
THEM AS WELL.
SPEAKER:  I WANT TO KNOW, HERE
IN THE AUDIENCE, COMES FROM
MASSACHUSETTS, FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS, HE AND I, HIS
WIFE, AND A COUPLE OF OTHER
FOLKS HAVE GONE UP TO QUINSY AT
THE END OF APRIL FOR A CEREMONY.
UNITED COMBAT VETERANS OF QUINS,
WHY, 95% OF VETERANS WHO SERVED
IN THE MARINE CORE.  TALK ABOUT
VETERANS, YOU HAVE IT.  AND YOU
USED TO GO DOWN TO THE CLOCK
TOWER.  48 OF THE SONS OF QUINSY
WHO DIED DURING THE VIETNAM
WAR.
THEY WOULD READ THE NAMES AND GO
TO THIS FAIRLY AWFUL CHINESE
RESTAURANT.  BUT THERE WAS A
CERTAIN LOYALTY THERE.  AND
WHEN THEY ADDED BOB'S BROTHER'S
NAME TO THE ROSTER OF THE DEAD,
THINGS STARTED TO CHANGE.  YOU
HAD A SITUATION WHERE MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE STARTED COMING,
POLITICAL LEADERS STARTED
COMING.  FOLKS LIKE PAUL
BUCKHAM, HONOR RECIPIENT WAS A
GUEST SPEAKER.  THIS YEAR
GENERAL JOE DUNFORD, CHAIRMAN OF
THE JOINT CHIEF OF STAFF, ALSO
QUINSY RESIDENT, CAME TO GIVEN
THE KEYNOTE SPEECH.  HE HAD A
SITUATION WHERE THE COMMUNITY
EMBRACES THOSE WHO SERVE AND
TRIES TO HELP THEM HEAL.  IT'S A
SMALL PART OF THE COMMUNITY.
BUT IT'S ALWAYS, IT SEEMS,
VETERANS HELPING VETERANS.
THOSE WHO DIDN'T SERVE, YOU
DON'T GET IT THE SAME WAY.  A
LOT OF NONVETERANS WILL SAY
WELCOME HOME.  THAT'S NICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THAT'S NICE.  BUT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT.  WHEN A VETERAN
SAYS THAT TO SOMEONE WHO HAS
COME BACK, IT HAS A DIFFERENT
CONTEXT ALMOST.  AND IN QUINSY,
IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT I THINK
A LOT OF OTHER COMMUNITIES CAN
DO AND SHOULD DO.  NOT ONLY FOR
THE YOUNGER GUYS, BUT FOR ALL
VETERANS.  A LOT OF THE VETERANS
TREATMENT COURTS, THERE ARE
MORE VIETNAM ERA VETERANS THAN
THERE ARE IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN
VETERANS.
SPEAKER:  RIGHT.
SPEAKER:  WHEN YOU WERE
MENTIONING THE FILM CLIP WE SAW.
22 VETERANS COMMIT SUICIDE EVERY
DAY.
SPEAKER:  20.
SPEAKER:  IT SAID 22 THERE.
SPEAKER:  EVEN ONE A DAY IS TOO
MUCH.
SPEAKER:  SOMETHING LIKE 70% OF
THOSE VETERANS ARE AGE 55 AND
OLDER.  THEY'RE NOT THE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO CAME BACK.  THE
CONNOTATION WAS HERE LOOK AT THE
DAMAGED PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
HOME.  A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE AMONG --
SPEAKER:  ONE OF THE LARGEST
HOMELESS POPULATIONS IN OUR
COUNTRY IS VETERANS FROM THE
VIETNAM WAR.
SPEAKER:  AND EXCUSE ME, I WOULD
ARGUE.  HERE IS A DISCUSSION
POINT.  OKAY.  BECAUSE NOT ALL
OF YOU ARE IN THE AUDIENCE AND
ARE VETERANS.  WHAT BERNIE SAID
ABOUT THE VETERANS IN THE
COMMUNITY IS FINE.  TO DRAW
VETERANS TOGETHER.  WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS, INSTEAD OF HAVING
VETERANS NIGHT AT THE BALLPARK,
TAKE THE RESOURCES THAT ARE USED
TO DO THAT, MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH OFFICE
IS NOT ONLY OPEN 24/7 SEVERAL
DAYS A WEEK, BUT IS STAFFED WITH
SOMEBODY THAT CAN HANDLE
MILITARY PTSD OR MST.  THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE COMMUNITY CAN
DO TO HELP OUR VETERANS.  THE.
SPEAKER:  GREG, LET ME ASK YOU
THIS: ESPECIALLY NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RESOURCES THAT MAY
BE TIGHTENING UP AND BUDGETS
MAY BE CHANGING AND THERE MAY
NOT BE AS MUCH MONEY TO HELP
FUND PROGRAMS THAT ARE THERE.
WHAT CAN PEOPLE DO?  I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO DEAL WITH
FOLKS RURAL.
I'M FROM A SMALLER TOWN OUTSIDE
OF CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW PEOPLE
IN OUR POPULATIONS ENDED UP
GOING IN AND LISTING INTO THE
MILITARY.  WHAT DO FOLKS IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES DO?  HOW DO
THEY DEAL WITH WARRIORS WHO
BECOME SOMEWHAT ISOLATED AND
PERHAPS TURN TO DRUGS AND
ALCOHOL AS AN ESCAPE, WHAT DO
YOU THINK FOR THEM?
SPEAKER:  NUMBER ONE, NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF CORRECTIONS
PROVIDES TRAINING.  AND IF THEY
ARE LOOKING TO IMPLEMENT A
VETERANS CORE TREATMENT PROGRAM,
CAN CONTACT NIC AT NIC.GOV AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT WHETHER YOU
WANT TO START A TREATMENT COURT
OR SOME OTHER PROGRAMMING.  OR
THEY CAN CONTACT JUSTICE
FOR VETS OR THERE IS GRANTS
AVAILABLE.  BUT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR POPULATION AND I
THINK DATA DRIVES A LOT OF
DECISIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND IF YOU CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
MANY VETERANS YOU HAVE IN YOUR
JAIL OR CASE LOADS, I THINK THEY
CAN HELP LEAD TO WARRANTING A
PROGRAM IN YOUR JURISDICTION.
DON'T JUST ASK IF YOU'RE A
VETERAN.  SOMETIMES THEY ONLY
THINK YOU'RE ONLY A VETERAN IF
YOU SERVED IN COMBAT.  YOU HAVE
TO ASK, HAVE YOU SERVED IN THE
MILITARY.  ONCE YOU HAVE
JUSTIFIED YOUR PROGRAMMING.  AND
I THINK JUDGE PETERSON I THINK
YOU CAN SPEAK TO THIS.  YOU CAN
CREATE SOMETHING WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES.
SPEAKER:  YEAH I'M DYING TO
KNOW, IF WE HAD 5,000 JUDGES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SITTING HERE
WATCHING THIS, WHAT CAN YOU TELL
THEM ABOUT THINGS BEING
MODIFIED ABOUT RETURNING VETS
WHO MAY BE DEALING WITH SOME OF
THE ISSUES?
SPEAKER:  I TELL THEM FIRST,
YOU'RE GOING TO PROSECUTE THESE
GUYS ANYWAY.  YOU'RE GOING TO
DEFEND THEM.  THEY'RE GOING TO
BE CHARGED AND HAVE THE COURT
CLERK PULL THE FILE.  WHY DON'T
YOU PUT THEM ALL ON THE SAME
DOCKET?  IT DOESN'T COST YOU ANY
MORE TO DO THAT.  AND FROM THAT
YOU CAN DEVELOP A VETERANS
COURT DOCKET AND YOU CAN START
LOOKING INTO LOCAL RESOURCES.
AT SOME POINT IN TIME I REMEMBER
TALKING TO JUDGE RUSSEL AND
THERE WAS A CONCERN ABOUT MAKING
COOKIE CUTTER COURTS AND ALL OF
THE VETERANS COURTS WOULD LOOK
ALIKE.
THE REALITY IS EVERYONE HAS A
DIFFERENT GROUP OF VETERANS.  IN
IDAHO, 90% IS MARINES.  AND IN
OUR JURISDICTION, IT'S ARMY.
AND SOME COURTS WILL HANDLE
FELONY-LEVEL EVENTS AND SOME DO
MISDEMEANOR EVENTS.  AND SOME DO
A COMBINATION.
BUT YOU CAN DO THIS AND SET A
PROGRAM TOGETHER AND SET UP THE
DOCKETS.  IT DOESN'T COST YOU
ANYTHING.
SPEAKER:  YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT
PUTTING RESOURCES TOGETHER.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE CHARGED WITH
THE CRIME AND GO THROUGH THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM BUT YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE ONE ON ONE.  WITH THE
VETS.
SPEAKER:  EACH COURT HAS
DEVELOPED THEIR OWN MENTORIZED
SYSTEM.  WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
FORUM.  MEETS ONCE A MONTH AND
EVERY VETERAN HAS TO ATTEND SIX
FORUMS.  IF YOU HAVE 12 MONTHS
OF PROBATION, YOU LOSE A MONTH
OF PROBATION EVERY TIME YOU COME
TO THE FORUM.  THE INCENTIVE IS
TO COME TO THE FORUM.  AT THE
FORUM, WE FEED THEM AND GIVE
THEM A DINNER AND THEN WE HAVE
THEM SET UP A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
COMMUNITY RESOURCES FOR CHILD
SUPPORT AND LICENSING FOR
DRIVER'S LICENSE AND LANDLORD
TENANT ATTORNEYS AND WE PUT
EVERY RESOURCE AVAILABLE TO A
VETERAN IN ONE ROOM.  AFTER WE
GO THROUGH THE RESOURCE
PORTIONS, GO THROUGH TWO
ONE-HOUR THERAPY SESSIONS.  AND
AFTER THAT GET THROUGH THE
PROGRAM.
SPEAKER:  LET ME STOP YOU.  A
LOT OF THE RESOURCES THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.  IN MOST CASES
IT'S A PHONE CALL.  THEY ARE
WILLING TO VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME
AND SERVICE BECAUSE OF THE
POPULATION WE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
GREG YOU HAD SOMETHING?
SPEAKER:  YEAH, I WANT TO SAY,
YOU CAN LOOK AT TREATMENT COURTS
FOR VETS.  YOU CAN ASK YOUR
JURISDICTION.  YOU CAN CONTACT
JUSTICE FOR VETS.  THEY HAVE
FOUR MENTOR COURTS.  AND YOU CAN
MAKE A REQUEST TO TAKE A TEAM
ON SITE AND SEE WHAT IS GOING ON
AND VIEW THAT COURT.
SPEAKER:  YEAH, IF YOU ARE IN
ANY WAY INTERESTED IN GOING TO
THE VETERANS COURT.  GO TO THE
WEBSITE.
SPEAKER:  LET ME DO THIS REAL
QUICK.  TIM, WHEN YOU CAME BACK,
THE GOAL WITH PTSD IS FIGURING
OUT THE DIAGNOSIS AND WHAT YOU
ARE UP AGAINST AND INTERVENING
IT AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO YOU
CAN HELP THAT FROM TURNING TO
REALLY BAD DECISIONS AND
ULTIMATELY TURNING INTO SOMEBODY
WHO PERHAPS ACTS OUT AND COULD
BE COMMITTING CRIMES.
WHAT COULD HAVE BEEN THE THING
THAT IMMEDIATELY INTERCEPTED YOU
WHEN COMING BACK FROM COMBAT
IMMENSELY?
SPEAKER:  VETERANS COURT.  NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND.  I WOULDN'T
HAVE HAD SEVEN ARRESTS AND
WOULDN'T HAVE SPENT YEARS IN MY
LIFE IN PRISONS.  I WOULD HAVE
BEEN IN MY DAUGHTER'S LIFE.
SPEAKER:  YOU NEED A VET TO TELL
YOU, YOU ARE A CHANGED MAN.
YOU CAN FIGURE THIS OUT.
SPEAKER:  YEAH, AND I NEED A
ROOM WHERE YOU CAN WALK IN AND
THE RESOURCES ARE RIGHT THERE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE PERPLEXED
THAT VETERAN
COURTS WORK.  IN REALITY, IT'S
ONE STAFF, ONE JUDGE, ONE
COURTROOM, ONE DAY A WEEK.
SPEAKER:  THEY ARE SPEAKING YOUR
LANGUAGE.
SPEAKER:  THEY ARE SPEAKING MY
LANGUAGE AND I CAN WALK INTO
THAT ROOM AND GET EVERYTHING
THAT I NEED.  YOU CAN'T GET THAT
ANYWHERE ELSE.
SPEAKER:  AND EVEN BEFORE ALL
THAT, IF SOMEBODY COMMITS A
CRIME, THE FIRST PEOPLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO COME ACROSS
ARE THE POLICE.  AND THE
JUSTICE-INVOLVED VETERANS
NETWORK IS ONE GENTLEMAN,
CAPTAIN BLAIR MYHAND IN NORTH
CAROLINA.
SPEAKER:  NOW CHIEF.
SPEAKER:  OKAY.  THAT I DIDN'T
KNOW.  AND WHAT HE DOES IS HE
TAKES A COUPLE OF VETS WHO ARE
ON THE POLICE FORCE, AND TRAINS
THEM IN HOW TO DEAL WITH A
CRISIS IF SOMEBODY IS A VETERAN
AND IF THEY KNOW THE PERSON IS A
VETERAN BECAUSE THE SPOUSE
TELLS THE FIRST, THESE GUYS COME
AND THEY KNOW WHAT TO SAY AND
THEY KNOW HOW TO BRING SOMEBODY
DOWN FROM THE CRISIS HE IS IN OR
SHE IS IN.  AND ALSO DOES THIS
TRAINING FOR OTHER POLICE
DEPARTMENTS.  I THINK TWICE A
YEAR.  BUT THE POLICE HAVE A
GREATER ROLE THAT THEY CAN PLAY.
AND IT'S NOT GOING ON NEARLY AS
MUCH.
SPEAKER:  IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
THE BARRIER RIGHT NOW THAT
EXISTS, ESPECIALLY WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT?  A LOT OF MY
FRIENDS WHO ARE POLICE OFFICERS
TEND TO GIVEN THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT TO A RETURNING VET.  THEY
WILL PAT THEM ON THE BACK AND
SAY DON'T DO THIS.  IS THAT
DOING THEM A FAVOR OR IS THAT
HURTING THEM?  YOU ARE BASICALLY
IN DENIAL.  YOU'RE A VET.  I'M
CUTTING YOU SOME SLACK HERE.
SPEAKER:  IN MY OPINION IT'S
DEFINITELY HURTING THEM.
SPEAKER:  JUST A KICK IN THE
CAN.
SPEAKER:  DEFINITELY.  ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS IN MY
JOB IS TO DO CRISIS INTERVENTION
TRAINING WITH THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.  I GO OVER TO THE
PHILADELPHIA POLICE DEPARTMENT
AND GO OVER TO CAMDEN, NEW
JERSEY AND TELL THEM MY STORY
FLAT OUT.  THE BEST THING THAT
HAPPENED TO ME WAS GETTING THAT
FINAL ARREST AND NOT GETTING LET
GO THAT WAY AND ACTUALLY
GETTING PUT IN A VETERANS COURT.
IT ABSOLUTELY CHANGED MY LIFE.
I EDUCATE THE POLICE ON PTSD,
TBI, YOU KNOW, DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
WHICH IS VERY HIGH AMONGST
VETERANS.
AND I TELL MY STORY.  AND IT
REALLY STRIKES HOME WITH THEM.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY
THEY'RE THE FIRST RESPONDERS AND
THE ONES OUT ON THE STREET
COMING IN CONTACT WITH THESE
VETERANVETERANS.  THE ONES OUT
THERE BUYING HEROIN AND GETTING
IN BAR FIGHTS AND STUFF LIKE
THAT.
THEY ARE SHOWING UP ON THE SCENE
AND THE DECISIONS THEY MAKE
THAT DAY CAN ABSOLUTELY CHANGE
THEIR LIFE FOR THE BETTER.
GETTING ARRESTED IS NOT THE
WORST THING THAT CAN HAPPEN TO
THE VET.
SPEAKER:  IT CAN BE KICKING A
CAN DOWN THE ROAD.  BUT UNLESS
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU ARE DOING, YOU
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND YOUR
RESOURCES IN THE COMMUNITY AND
HAVE TO BE WILLING TO MAKE A
REFERRAL.  I THINK SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE WORKING ON IN
NIC AND WITH FOLKS UP HERE REAL
QUICK, INCREASING WHAT THEY CALL
THE RESPONSIBILITY ISSUES OF
VETERANS.  AND LOOKING AT
DEVELOPING TRAINING AND CULTURE
AS YOU ARE TRANSITIONING FROM
MILITARY TO CIVILIAN LIFE AND
WORKING ON THE CURRICULUM FOR
THE INNOVATION AND HOPING TO
MAKE THIS AVAILABLE TO THE
FIELD.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT, THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT PARTNERED
WITH BUR
EAU OF JUSTICE ASSISTANCE TO
WORK WITH A COMPREHENSIVE TOOL
AND PROTOCOL TO HELP BEST SERVE
THE VETERANS IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
SPEAKER:  OKAY.  WE JUST HAVE A
FEW MINUTES LEFT FOR THE PANEL.
I WANT TO GET SOME CLOSING
REMARKS.  IF WE CAN GET IT BRIEF
THOUGH AS WE GO DOWN THE LINE.
AT THE END.  IS THERE A HOPEFUL
MESSAGE TO PASS ALONG.  WHAT IS
IT THAT YOU HOPE WOULD HAPPEN
FOR YEARS TO COME?  WE HAVE
ALREADY IDENTIFIED THE PROBLEM.
WE'RE A NATION OF LIKING TO FIX
PROBLEMS.  WE WILL START WITH
YOU TIM AT THE END.
SPEAKER:  I HOPE THAT ALL OF THE
WORK UP UNTIL THIS POINT DOES
NOT GO TO WASTE AND I HOPE THAT
THE PEOPLE KEEP THEIR FIRE LIT
AND KEEP THEIR FOOT TO THE PEDAL
AND KEEP THEIR FEET ON THE GAS.
TO CLEAR UP ANY TIME SOON.  WE
HAVE VIETNAM VETS WHO ARE COMING
INTO OUR COURTS WHO HAVE NEVER
DEALT WITH ANYTHING FOR YEARS
AND YEARS AND YEARS AND COMING
INTO THE COURTS AND CHANGING
THEIR LIVES AROUND.  IT'S NEVER
TOO LATE.  IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN.  IT'S
ABOUT VIETNAM VETS AND A TON OF
VETERANS OUT THERE GOING THROUGH
CERTAIN THINGS IN THEIR LIVES.
AS A COMMUNITY AND AS A NATION
TO COMBAT THIS.
WE NEED TO STICK TOGETHER AND
EDUCATE OURSELVES.  EVERYBODY
NEEDS TO BE EDUCATED IN THIS
AREA IN VETERANS ISSUES IF WE
WANT TO SUCCEED.
SPEAKER:  TOM?
SPEAKER:  I WOULD JUST ECHO WHAT
TIM SAID.  KEEP UP THE GOOD
WORK FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
LEARNED SOMETHING TODAY, TAKE IT
BACK TO YOUR COMMUNITY AND PUSH
IT.  AS FAR AS YOU CAN.
SPEAKER:  JUDGE?
SPEAKER:  ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THERAPEUTIC FACTORS
FOR ANY VETERANS IS SIMPLY
TALKING TO ANOTHER VETERAN.  WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT HAPPEN
PRIOR TO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
INVOLVEMENT.  BUT CERTAINLY THE
VETERANS TALKING TO VETERANS IS
ONE OF THE BEST THERAPIES
AVAILABLE OUT THERE.  THE
COMMUNITIES NEED TO GET
INVOLVED.  THE COMMUNITIES NEED
TO GET DEEPER INTO THE VETERANS
SYSTEM AND UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THEM AND DO AS
MUCH PRE-EMPTIVE THINGS THEY CAN
DO.  IT DOESN'T REALLY COST A
LOT OF MONEY TO DO IT.
SPEAKER:  BERNIE?
SPEAKER:  NEXT TIME OUR
GOVERNMENT MAKES A DECISION TO
SEND MEN AND WOMEN, MOSTLY
YOUNG, OFF TO WAR, THEY NEED TO
ALSO PLAN FISCALLY FOR WHEN
THESE FOLKS COME BACK.  SO THAT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS FOR THEM.
THAT DOES NOT GO ON.  ONCE
YOU'RE USED UP, TOO OFTEN THE
MILITARY WANTS TO SAY BYE BYE TO
YOU.  AND PEOPLE COME BACK AND
THEY ARE -- THEY HAVEN'T
REACCLIMATED AND THEY ARE
DRIFTING AND THEY ARE HURTING
AND THEN THEY GET -- TOO MANY OF
THEM GET IN TROUBLE.  WE NEED
TO, IF YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON WAR,
SPEND A COUPLE OF BILLION, PUT
IT AWAY TO BUILD UP YOUR
RESOURCES HERE.  WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT A LOT OF THE RESOURCES FOR
WHEN THE TROOPS COME BACK AND
YOU KNOW DAMN WELL THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF THEM WHO
ARE SUFFERING FROM TBI AND PTSD
AND ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION.  YOU
GOT TO HELP THESE GUYS BEING
PROACTIVE IN DOING IT.
SPEAKER:  WELL FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK YOU AGAIN JONATHAN
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT, BERNIE, YOU
TOUCHED ON IT.  VETERANS
TYPICALLY WANT TO HELP VETERANS
AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THESE
PANEL MEMBERS I CALLED, AND
THERE WASN'T EVEN A HESITATION
THAT THEY WANTED TO HELP.  THERE
WASN'T A HESITATION THAT YOU
WANTED TO BE HERE.  I WOULD SAY
TO YOU IF YOU'RE IN A
JURISDICTION SOMEWHERE YOU GOT
TO FIND A CHAMPION AND DON'T
TAKE NO FOR AN ANSWER.  THERE IS
A LOT OF HELP OUT THERE FOR
FOLKS WHO WANT TO IMPLEMENT SOME
SORT OF VETERANS PLANNING.
SPEAKER:  I WANT TO THANK THE
ENTIRE PANEL.  THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.  AND ONE FINAL THOUGHT.
AS YOU HAVE HEARD A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT VETERANS
TALKING TO VETERANS, I WOULD
IMPLORE FOLKS, IF YOU'RE A
CIVILIAN, AND YOU CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE SUBJECT, THESE ARE OUR
WARRIORS THAT WE SEND OFF TO
SERVE AND SACRIFICE, IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO OPEN UP A CENTER
LIKE THIS AND FACILITATE IT.
PLEASE DO.  YOU CAN CALL THE
NUMBERS THAT WE HAVE MADE
AVAILABLE TO YOU.  GO TO THE
WEBSITE.  LOOK IT UP.  PUT IT
TOGETHER YOURSELF.  IT WILL MAKE
A HUGE DIFFERENCE.  YOU
ACTUALLY COULD SAVE A LIFE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.  THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU, SIR.
APPRECIATE IT.
SPEAKER:  MY PLEASURE.
SPEAKER:  WE DO HAVE A FEW
MINUTES FOR QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS, IF PEOPLE WANT TO STAY
BEHIND.  WE HAVE GOT ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES TO TAKE QUICK
QUESTIONS.
SPEAKER:  ALL RIGHT.
SPEAKER:  ANDREW, YOU WANT SOME
Q AND A GOING?  IF ANYBODY HAS
QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL, YOU CAN
STAY FOR A FEW MINUTES AND ASK
WHAT YOU WOULD LIKE.
SPEAKER:  I'M A VIETNAM VETERAN
AND I'M A MENTOR AT THE FAIRFAX,
VIRGINIA VETERANS COURT DOCKET.
AND THEN ASK THE JUDGE A
QUESTION.  THE COMMENCE IS OUR
PARTICULAR VETERANS COURT WAS
THE FIRST IN VIRGINIA TO GET
STARTED.  ITS BEEN A SLOW
PROCESS.  WE HAVE GOTTEN A FEW
PEOPLE THROUGH TO GRADUATE.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IS WHETHER
WE HAVE ENOUGH INCENTIVES TO
OFFER TROUBLED VETERANS
GOING THROUGH THE PROGRAM.  FOR
EXAMPLE THERE MAY BE A FEW WITH
MULTIPLE DUIS.
AND WHEN THEY ARE PRESENTED WITH
THE CHOICE OF WHETHER TO GO
INTO THE PROGRAM OR WHETHER TO
SERVE TIME, THEY DECIDE TO SERVE
TIME BECAUSE THEIR CHARGES ARE
NOT EXPUNGED FROM THE RECORD IN
THE STATE OF VIRGINIA.  AND
THAT, I UNDERSTAND AND SOME OF
THE VETERANS COURT DOCKETS IN
THE COUNTRY, EXPUNGEMENT IS A
POSSIBILITY.  AND IS AN
INCENTIVE TO GET TROUBLED
VETERANS THROUGH THE PROGRAM.
THE SECOND ISSUE THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR YOU ADDRESS, BEING
THE FIRST VETERANS COURT DOCKET
IN VIRGINIA, WE HAVE GONE TO
RICHMOND TO LOBBY POLITICALLY TO
EXPAND THE VETERANS COURT
DOCKET PROGRAM IN THE STATE.
AND WE RUN INTO PROBLEMS
POLITICALLY WITH SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN, MANY OF THEM
CONSERVATIVE.  WHO DON'T SEE
THE VALUE OF THE VETERANS COURT
DOCKET PROGRAMS.  THEY THINK,
WHY GIVE VETERANS SPECIAL
TREATMENT COMPARED TO THE REST
OF THE POPULATION.  AND IT'S A
MAJOR PROBLEM.  WE WOULD LOVE TO
SEE THIS PROGRAM EXPAND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.  HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH THAT?  HOW CAN WE
CHANGE SOME OF THE POLITICAL
ATTITUDES IN THE STATE CAPITOLS?
SPEAKER:  I KEEP RUNNING INTO
THAT ON A DAILY BASIS.  IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME TO GO AND
ASK FOR ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
WE FUND MOST OF OUR STUFF
LOCALLY.
BUT THE QUESTION, WHY VETERANS
COURTS?  I HAD, ODDLY ENOUGH, A
PUBLIC DEFENDER COME UP TO SEE
AND SAY WHY DO YOU WANT TO HAVE
A VETERANS COURT?  THE NEXT
THING YOU WILL HAVE A SPECIAL
COURT FOR POLICE AND SPECIAL
COURT FOR FIREMEN AND WE ALREADY
HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH COURT AND
A DRUG COURT.  WHY DO THIS?
VETERANS DON'T NECESSARILY FIT
INTO THOSE SYSTEMS.  AND ONE OF
MY EXAMPLES THAT I JUST USED WAS
OKAY.  IN NO OTHER JOB IN THE
WORLD WILL YOU HAVE A
21-YEAR-OLD SERGEANT.  THERE IS
GUN FIRE OVER THERE, CHECK IT
OUT.  THERE IS NO OTHER JOB.
AND AFTER YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED
THAT.  AND AFTER YOU HAVE GONE
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PROCESS YOU
WILL NEVER COME BACK AND BE A
CIVILIAN AGAIN.  YOU WILL ALWAYS
BE A VETERAN.  YOU MIGHT HAVE A
DRUG PROBLEM AND MIGHT HAVE A
MENTAL HEALTH HOW AND HAVE TBI
OR PTSD, THAT COURT WILL MAKE
THEM SUCCESSFUL.  RATES MOST
VETERANS COURTS 11%.  THESE
COURTS ARE SUCCESSFUL.  THESE
MENTEES AND VETERANS DON'T COME
BACK AFTER THE PROGRAM.  IT'S A
HARD PUSH WHEN YOU ARE DEALING
WITH THE GUYS THAT HOLD THE
MONEY.  THEY HAVE TO BE
CONVINCED.  BUT IF YOU CAN DO IT
WITHOUT THAT MONEY.  IF YOU
START OUT ON YOUR OWN, YOU CAN
MAKE THEM EAT THEIR WORDS.
SPEAKER:  AND I GOT TO
REITERATE, YOU HAVE GOT TO WORK
OUT YOUR NUMBERS AND FIND OUT
HOW MANY VETERANS ARE IN YOUR
STATE.
SPEAKER:  WE HAVE HAD
SITUATIONS, ONE IN PARTICULAR,
THERE HAVE BEEN A COUPLE OF
VETERANS TREATMENT COURTS THAT
HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN SEVERAL
COUNTIES IN ARIZONA AND THERE